donc l'ordre du jour appelle la séance
de questions au gouvernement et la
première d'entre elles va être posée par
Madame Mélanie Thomas pour le groupe
socialiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre votre réforme est un
concentré d'illusion perdu alors que
votre projet de texte arrive à peine à
la disposition des parlementaires les
Français ont déjà fait la démonstration
de leur opposition votre Ministre Franck
Riester l'a voulu lui-même les femmes
davantage que les hommes seront plus
lourdement pénalisés par votre report de
l'âge
pour la génération 80 l'effort des
femmes sera deux fois plus important que
l'effort fournis par les hommes au SMIC
à temps partiel carrière fractionnée
carrière hachée vous parlez des femmes
sans humanité secrétaire aide à domicile
caissières ouvrière agricole doivent
déjà composer avec 40 % de pension de
mois que les hommes les trois quarts des
petites retraites se sont-elles les
femmes première victime de la décote
vous attaquez leur belles années après
une vie de labeurs alors votre
revalorisation à 1200 euros brut
exclusivement pour les carrières
complètes quelles tromperie et surtout
quelle plus-value quand la plupart de
ces femmes n'ont pas cotisé comme des
hommes pour masquer ses imperfections
vous avez trouvé une solution miracle
nous faire travailler plus longtemps or
votre réforme ne fait que reproduire des
inégalités existantes on ne transforme
pas on aggrave
alors on comprend bien toute votre
contradiction le suffrage universel
avait pourtant rendu son verdict un
message clair adressé au président pas
de majorité absolue pour mener à pas
forcer cette réforme madame la Première
ministre considérant ces écailles
majeurs pour la défense des femmes des
catégories moyennes et populaires quand
votre gouvernement compte il retirer
cette réforme
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Mélanie Thomas je ne peux pas laisser
dire que notre projet ne protégerait pas
les femmes
au contraire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît on écoute la réponse de
la première ministre alors
alors
alors s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues c'est une séance de questions
au Gouvernement madame Thomas posé une
question j'attends la réponse du
gouvernement donc écoutez là s'il vous
plaît
au contraire nous réduisons les
inégalités inacceptables entre les
femmes et les hommes au moment de la
retraite nous protégeons nous protégeons
les femmes qui ont des carrières
incomplètes et hachées les femmes qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt les femmes
qui ont des petites pensions les femmes
seront les premières bénéficiaires de la
revalorisation les femmes seront les
premières bénéficiaires de la
revalorisation des petites pensions
elles sont aujourd'hui plus nombreuses à
avoir cotisées avec des revenus modestes
et grâce à la revalorisation de la
retraite minimale près d'un tiers
d'entre elles vont voir leur pension
augmenter pour les retraités actuels
notre projet bénéficie là encore
davantage aux femmes d'augmentation
moyenne
s'il vous plaît
donc je le redis pour les retraités
actuels notre projet bénéficie là encore
davantage aux femmes l'augmentation
moyenne des petites pensions sera deux
fois plus élevée pour elle que pour les
hommes
par ailleurs nous pendrons prendreons
désormais en compte pour le calcul des
droits les trimestres en congés parental
c'est vrai à la fois pour la retraite
minimale mais aussi pour l'intégration
dans le dispositif dit de carrière
longue ainsi les femmes qui ont commencé
à travailler tôt seront mieux protégés
enfin 20% des femmes 20% des femmes
doivent travailler jusqu'à 67 ans pour
bénéficier d'une retraite à taux plein
malgré la hausse de l'âge légal nous
maintenons à 67 ans l'âge de départ à
taux plein
pour les femmes qui ont connu des
interruptions de carrière souvent subies
l'âge de départ ne changera donc pas
mais mesdames et messieurs les députés
notre projet est juste et porteur de
progrès social
mais nous devons veiller à l'avenir de
notre système de retraite c'est pourquoi
nous demandons à celles et ceux qui le
peuvent de travailler progressivement
plus longtemps y compris des femmes qui
ont eu des carrières complètes cependant
cependant les femmes continueront à
partir plutôt que les hommes j'ajoute
que les femmes bénéficieront de
meilleures pensions de fait la réforme
contribuera à réduire l'écart de pension
entre les hommes et les femmes je le
redis nous avons veillé avec le ministre
Olivier du soft en construisant ce
projet à protéger les plus fragiles les
plus modestes y compris les femmes mais
madame la députée au-delà de ce faux
procès j'espère que les débats dans
l'hémicycle nous permettront de
continuer à enrichir le projet je vous
remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
allez-y madame Thomas
nous savons bien que vos mesures ne
s'appliqueront qu'à une minorité de
femmes partout en France elles sont
mobilisées
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame Lise manier pour
le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'agriculture et la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre un vent
glacial d'inquiétude et de désarroi
souffle sur nos plaines agricoles depuis
la semaine dernière à quelques semaines
seulement des semis de betteraves et
24000 planteurs et l'ensemble des
salariés de la filière betteravière tous
des emplois situés dans notre ruralité
ont appris avec stupeur la décision de
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
d'interdire totalement l'utilisation des
néonicotinoïdes
lors de la campagne de 2020 la première
campagne sans néonicotinoïdes la
production dans mon département la Marne
avait baissé de plus de 25%. d'autres
départements avaient connu une baisse de
plus de 60%. en tout 40% des planteurs
avaient connu une baisse de plus de 30%
de leur production aujourd'hui les
planteurs refusent catégoriquement de
revivre un tel traumatisme les
industriels s'inquiètent clairement pour
leur outil en cas de baisse massive des
surfaces et des rendements les filières
connexes le bioéthanol ou aussi la
luzerne pourrait subir à court terme des
répercussions tout aussi majeures
alors même que la France est aujourd'hui
le premier pays producteur de sucre
d'Europe et alors même qu'à ce stade
aucune solution scientifique ou
agronomique n'a fait ses preuves pour
protéger les cultures de betteraves du
puceron et de la jaunisse malgré
l'engagement collectif des planteurs
industriels semencier chercheurs
responsable politique et
environnementaux dans un plan national
de recherche et d'innovation depuis 3
ans ce coup d'arrêt brutal mais en
question notre souveraineté alimentaire
et notre souveraineté industrielle ma
question est donc double monsieur le
ministre à très court terme d'abord afin
de rassurer l'ensemble de la filière
pouvez-vous nous assurer qu'ils seront
entièrement indemnisés des potentiels
pertes liés à la jaunisse pouvez-vous
aussi nous confirmer qu'à l'échelle
européenne aucune distorsion de
concurrence ne sera possible et je pense
notamment à l'Allemagne merci Monsieur
le Ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Marc phénom au ministre de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire madame
la présidente madame la députée manier
merci de votre question qui me permet
effectivement de d'éclairer notre
discussion par rapport à la décision de
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
qui a décidé d'interdire purement et
simplement l'utilisation en enrobage
des néonicotinoïdes et avec une
application immédiate nous savions très
bien que nous étions sur la voie d'une
progression qui nous a mené à la fin de
l'année 2023 au plus tard à la sortie
des néonicotinoïdes c'était d'ailleurs
le sens de la loi que vous avez votée
qui permettait de déroger mais qui dans
le même temps essayez de trouver des
solutions alternatives la difficulté
dans laquelle on se trouve c'est
qu'effectivement au milieu de cette
campagne c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
nous avions demandé une troisième
dérogation nous nous apprêtions à
expérimenter plus avant encore un
certain nombre de solutions qui
commencent à être sur la table et qui ne
sont pas abouties cette décision nous
impose de prendre un certain nombre de
décisions effectivement vis-à-vis des
planteurs et vis-à-vis de la filière
tout entière vis-à-vis des planteurs
c'est d'abord à court terme de leur
garantir que sur 2023 en cas
d'apparition de Johnny s'il puisse être
couvert intégralement des pertes qui
pourraient avoir du fait de l'apparition
par les pucerons de la jaunisse deuxième
élément deuxième les éléments c'est de
faire en sorte que nous rassurions aussi
vous l'avez raison les industriels parce
qu'il y a un certain nombre d'années
sociales qui ont besoin de betteraves
pour faire tourner et qui ont produit
des investissements importants donc nous
allons y travailler pour faire en sorte
qu'on soit en rendez-vous de cette de
cet élément là troisième élément la
recherche et l'innovation qui nous faut
accélérer à la fois avec le programme
tel qu'il avait été lancé et par
ailleurs avec des dispositions y compris
phytosanitaires qui sont existantes et
utilisables aujourd'hui et avec des
itinéraires tactiques qui leur
permettent de répondre la démagogie ça
serait de dire il faut pas respecter le
droit européen d'ailleurs c'est une
passe que vous avez dit le droit
européen il s'impose à nous et parfois
il nous a bien protégé dans un certain
nombre de domaines la démagogie ça
serait de faire croire qu'il y a
d'autres voix possible et la
responsabilité c'est de dire ce que nous
faisons ce que nous allons faire pour
sauver la filière parce que nous avons
besoin de cette filière vous l'avez dit
pour le sucre pour l'éthanol pour un
certain nombre des éléments et donc
c'est bien ça qui massivement sera
déployé par le gouvernement pour faire
en sorte de donner à court terme et à
moyen et long terme de la visibilité
enfin cette filière
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur
florianchoche pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à la première
ministre Madame Elisabeth borne le 24
avril 2022 au soir de du second tour de
l'élection présidentielle le président
de la République déclaré je sais que
nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté ce
jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite et
je veux ici les remercier et leur dire
que j'ai conscience que c'est votre
m'oblige pour les années à venir que de
chemin parcourus depuis le président de
la République ne se sent plus obligé il
se croit même légitime pour repousser
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
pourtant ne vous en déplaise les
Françaises et les Françaises ont fait le
choix de ne pas vous donner de majorité
absolue aujourd'hui nous sommes nombreux
sur ces bancs peut-être même sommes-nous
majoritaires à être contre le report à
l'âge à 64 ans de l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite c'est pourquoi vous faites
le choix de passer en force après avoir
fait adop le budget avec 10 49,3 vous
dégainez l'article 47 1 pour contraindre
la procédure parlementaire est limitée
les débats dans notre assemblée à 20
jours une disposition jamais utilisée
depuis 1958 vous refusez que nous
puissions discuter parce que vous avez
peur du résultat que de mépris pour
notre assemblée et le débat
parlementaire vous faites fille de
l'opposition des Françaises et des
Français au report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite les sondages le
montrent cette Français sur dix sont
opposés à votre réforme entendez-le même
lorsque deux millions de salariés font
le choix de manifester de perdre une
journée de salaire que répond votre
porte-parole je ne vois pas un million
de personnes dans la rue je vois un
million de personnes qu'il nous faut
convaincre nous ne voulons pas renoncer
respecter les Françaises et les
Françaises ils ont bien compris votre
projet ils sont opposés et voulons faire
savoir si vous êtes si sûr de votre fait
pourquoi ne laissez-vous pas notre
assemblée débattre ou même les
Françaises et les Français trancher la
question par référendum et si nous
avions l'autre évidence de rejeter votre
projet ou de l'amender utiliserez-vous
l'article 49-3
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députéchoch vous avez évoqué au début de
votre question le contexte de l'élection
présidentielle lors de l'élection
présidentielle le président de la
République alors candidat a indiqué de
manière extrêmement claire et parfois
même ça lui a été reproché sa volonté de
mener une réforme des retraites et il
avait indiqué qu'à ses yeux la méthode
la plus efficace était de porter l'âge
légal de départ à 65 ans vous avez dit
que il y avait des Français évidemment
qui au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle on voter pour lui malgré
cette réforme et sans lui apporter leur
soutien à cette réforme nous le savons
nous le savons mais c'est même Français
savent aussi les engagements qu'il avait
pris la réforme que nous présentons est
une réforme qui est nécessaire elle est
nécessaire parce que le déficit est le
déficit est avéré c'est un déficit à
12,5 milliards d'euros 2027 par an après
ce que 15 milliards en 2030 20 en 2035
nous avons la conviction qu'il faut
mener cette réforme à la fois pour
équilibrer le système de retraite mais
aussi pour on l'améliorer vous nous
interrogez sur la procédure
parlementaire en faisant référence à
l'article 47-1 l'article 47-1 nous
n'avons pas lieu de le déclencher nous
n'avons pas lieu de l'actionné c'est un
article qui dit que les projets de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
ont un délai de 20 jours pour examiner
un texte le texte que j'ai présenté hier
dans la commission des affaires sociales
fait 14 articles 14 articles pour 20
jours je crois que la représentation
nationale aura très largement le temps
d'être éclairé éclairé par ces débats
est éclairé par les débats en commission
et éclairé par le débat public à la fin
de ce débat il y aura un vote un vote
souverain de l'Assemblée nationale et je
ne préjuge du vote de personnes d'aucun
groupe d'aucun député mais ce vol sera
légitime et permettra de mettre en
oeuvre la réforme la seule chose
Monsieur le député qui pourrait empêcher
un vote qui pourrait empêcher d'aller au
bout du débat c'est l'obstruction mais
la balle est dans votre camp
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
allez-y mon cher collègue
les Français vous donne rendez-vous le
31 janvier pour la prochaine
manifestation pour leur montrer leur
refus de cette réforme
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien
Petavy pour le groupe écologiste
madame la Présidente
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
équilibre budgétaire système déficitaire
pérennité financière depuis maintenant
deux semaines les bons soldats du
gouvernement sont au garde à vous sur
les plateaux télé et Martel les mêmes
éléments de langage y a-t-il urgence à
réformer monsieur le ministre non et ni
les économistes ni le comité
d'orientation des retraites ne vous
donne raison la seule urgence pour vous
et de ramener le déficit en dessous de
3% du PIB ce n'est pas une réforme de
justice sociale c'est une réforme de
finance publique la réallurgence c'est
celle sur laquelle ne vous alertons
depuis des années c'est celle que j'ai
constaté de moi-même pendant mon
hospitalisation c'est la faillite d'un
système de santé et d'un modèle de
protection sociale désormais à double
vitesse ou vieillir en bonne santé
devient un privilège de classe l'urgence
elle est du côté des salariés et qui
chaque jour voit leurs conditions de
travail se dégrader davantage vous
souhaitez augmenter les pensions de
retraite augmenter les salaires l'un ne
peut pas aller sans l'autre
je pense aux soignants de l'hôpital de
Pontoise à 90% en arrêt maladie je pense
à cette infirmière gentiste qui
travaille de nuit depuis ses 25 ans qui
n'aura pas la possibilité de partir plus
tôt puisque là je l'égale est reporté
mais de se former pour prendre un métier
moins pénible une fois épuisé ces
premières lignes à qui vous promettez
une première prise en compte de la
pénibilité au travail vous ne leur
offrez qu'un fond dédié à l'usure et
nous devons le dire c'est la honte
monsieur le ministre d'un côté 160
milliards d'euros d'argent public pour
les entreprises privées et de l'autre un
budget pour la santé qui ne suit même
pas la progression de l'inflation elle
est là à l'urgence ainsi ma question est
simple comment comptez-vous réellement
prendre en compte la pénibilité pour les
métiers du soin et de l'accompagnement
qu'il soit en ville ou à l'hôpital à
domicile ou en EHPAD ou auprès des
personnes en situation de handicap
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Olivier du soft 2018 du
travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député Peytavi permettez-moi
d'abord si l'autoriser à vous dire au
nom du gouvernement que nous sommes
heureux que votre état de santé vous
permet de nous rejoindre et de
participer à notre avant
j'ai monsieur le député j'ai un point de
désaccord un point d'accord avec vous un
point de désaccord parce que nous
considérons je l'ai dit dans la réponse
précédente que la réforme que nous
présentons est nécessaire vous évoquez
le Conseil d'orientation des retraites
son rapport l'hypothèse centrale qui est
celle autour de laquelle tous les
gouvernements tous les parlementaires
ont toujours discuté de l'avenir du
système des retraites je l'ai dit je le
répète prévois un déficit chronique
vos,5 milliards d'euros des 2027 13,5 en
2030 et sur 10 ans ce sont 150 milliards
d'euros de dettes accumulées si nous ne
faisons rien et nous avons la volonté de
préserver ce système et de garantir
aussi sa survie sa pérennité pour les
générations qui nous suivent et donc
nous ne partageons pas ce degré
d'urgence nous sommes convaincus qu'il y
a urgence pas vous par contre là où je
vous rejoins c'est sur la question de la
prise en compte de la pénibilité des
soignants pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
et les chiffres sont extrêmement clairs
plus de 40% des soignants sont exposés à
des contraintes de rythme et d'intensité
et nous savons que la situation des
soignants aujourd'hui est une situation
qui est extrêmement complexe j'ai eu
l'occasion de le hier en commission les
affaires sociales selon que vous soyez
aide-soignant infirmier recruté avant
2010 ou après 2010 dans la fonction
publique hospitalière dans la fonction
publique territoriale ou dans le secteur
privé vous disposez pas ni les mêmes
protections du même droit au compte
professionnel de prévention ce que nous
faisons sur ce fameux CP va permettre
notamment soignants du secteur privé d'y
accéder puisqu'en abaissant les seuils
les points seront accessibles aux
soignants et puis nous avons mis en
place par la loi une nouveauté j'ai cru
comprendre que vous la trouviez
insuffisante mais les nouvelles et elle
est importante c'est effectivement un
fond de prévention de la pénibilité de
l'usure 100 millions d'euros par an 100
millions d'euros qui vont permettre de
financer la prévention de la pénibilité
la prévention de l'usure et la
reconversion c'est la première fois que
ça existe et je peux vous assurer que
cela représente des montants qui sont
extrêmement conséquents et qui vont nous
permettre d'apporter beaucoup de
réponses aux questions que vous avez
posées je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup
la parole est à monsieur Éric Girardin
pour le groupe Renaissance
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre du Travail du plein d'emploi et
de l'insertion en France nous disposons
d'un formidable système de solidarité
intergénérationnelle dans lequel les
actifs cotisent et mettent ta
disposition leur force de travail pour
financer le repos de nos aider or la
démographie et les réalités économiques
ont fortement changé depuis
l'après-guerre si le sol du système de
retraite est positif en 2023 le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites organismes
indépendants prévoit un déficit durable
de notre système de retraite allant
jusqu'à moins 21 milliards d'euros en
2035 avec un déficit cumulé d'ici 10 ans
de près de 150 milliards d'euros comme
vous l'avez précisé monsieur le ministre
à l'instant je tiens à rappeler devant
tous nos collègues cette réalité
économique et budgétaire gouverner c'est
prévoir c'est pourquoi notre
responsabilité tes collective et de
garantir une retraite à nos enfants et à
nos petits-enfants en s'assurant de la
pérennité de notre système de retraite
et son équilibre financier pour ce faire
nous proposons une réforme progressive
qui rendra notre système plus juste en
protégeant les salariés qui ont une
carrière longue et difficile en
protégeant les travailleurs handicapés
et en augmentant le minimum de pension
de 100 euros par mois pour une carrière
complète nous créerons également un
index senior afin que ceux-ci retrouve
toute leur place dans l'entreprise et
ses capitales monsieur le ministre en
complément de tous ces progrès vous avez
indiqué en commission vouloir avancer
sur l'amélioration de la formation et
sur les modalités qui permettent à des
étudiants et à des stagiaires de
racheter des trimestres dans un cadre où
l'on rallonge la durée de cotisation et
là je départ à la retraite alors que les
conditions actuelles de rachat sont
relativement restrictives ne pensez-vous
pas presque simplifier le recours à ce
mécanisme de rachat des trimestres
permettrait aux jeunes de mieux
s'approprier et de mieux s'impliquer
dans la construction de leur propre
retraite je vous remercie merci beaucoup
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier dupe ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci monsieur madame la
Présidente pardonnez-moi mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
Girardin je ne reviens pas sur
l'équilibre général de la réforme vous
l'avez rappelé avec justice et justesse
pardonnez-moi mais je me concentre sur
la question que vous posez concernant
les dispositifs de rachat de trimestre
il y a des possibilités de rachat de
trimestre effectivement possibilité de
racheter des trimestres consacrés à des
études et nous devons à la fois
améliorer l'information à très telle
qu'elle est adressée aux assurés nous
devons aussi desserrer les délais et
desserrer les contraintes pour que cette
possibilité de rachat se fasse à un
moment où les assurés soient en capacité
de le faire et dans des conditions qui
soient les plus abordables et les plus
acceptables il y a aussi une possibilité
qui existe et qui est extrêmement peu
connu c'est la possibilité de racheter
des trimestres de stage effectués à
l'occasion d'études ou en fin de cursus
d'études les conditions de rachat des
trimestres de stage sont
particulièrement avantageuses puisque
ces conditions de rachat font que le
trimestre peut être acheté à hauteur de
440 euros la loi de 2013 qui a permis ce
rachat de stage fixe à un délai de deux
ans après la fin du stage la possibilité
de rachat de stage c'est effectivement
trop court trop court parce que deux ans
après un stage ont peut-être encore en
étude et deux ans après un stage on peut
aussi être dans une situation
professionnelle qui ne permet pas le
rachat y compris pour les montants qui
sont ainsi fixés je suis d'ici la
science et le gouvernement est à travers
moi totalement ouvert à pouvoir aménager
et améliorer ses dispositifs de rachat
de stage je l'ai dit en réponse à une
question du député Maillard lors de la
commission des affaires sociales d'hier
à la fois en étendant le délai de rachat
en déterminant aussi un âge jusqu'auquel
on pourrait racheter le c'est trimestre
de stage un coup pour l'assurer qui lui
permette de reconstituer sa carrière
dans des conditions qui sont acceptables
et abordables à l'ensemble des actifs
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe Benz
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre l'INSEE vient de
publier les chiffres de la natalité pour
2022 ils sont préoccupants avec 19000
naissances de moins que l'année
précédente la natalité française
enregistre un recul historique dans le
même temps la mortalité augmente le
solde naturel est au plus bas jamais les
Français n'ont eu si peu d'enfants
depuis près d'eux 80 ans la démographie
est un enjeu essentiel pour l'avenir de
notre société la natalité et le soutien
en famille doivent être à la base de
toute politique pour redonner confiance
aux Français en parallèle vous vous
apprêtez à imposer aux Français une
réforme des retraites injustes indigne
et déconnecté de toute réalité humaine
car vous êtes aveuglé par votre
conception strictement comptable vous
considérez que puisque l'espérance de
vie a augmenté mais stagne désormais les
Français doivent travailler plus
longtemps mais la véritable question
humaine et sociale est vivons-nous en
meilleure santé la réponse est
malheureusement non par ailleurs il n'y
a pas de système de retraite par
répartition sans renouvellement des
générations or vous oubliez d'encourager
le principal facteur de croissance
économique la natalité qui justement
renouvelle les générations soutenir une
démographie dynamique sur le long terme
c'est la garantie d'équilibrer
durablement le système de retraite cette
assuré une solidarité naturelle entre
générations lors de la présidentielle
nous avions proposé un arsenal de mesure
de bon sens pour soutenir les familles
françaises la relance de la natalité est
un impératif pour la France elle doit
être une priorité nationale
madame la Première ministre
qu'allez-vous faire pour doter enfin la
France d'une ambitieuse politique de
relance de la natalité je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
mise de travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député vous évoquez la question
démographique et je fais évidemment le
lien avec la réforme des retraites que
nous menons nous avons une situation
démographique qui n'est pas nouvelle
dans les années 70 il y avait trois
cotisants pour un retraité et ça donne
toujours l'occasion de rappeler que ce
sont les actifs du moment qui cotisent
pour les retraités du moment et que
c'est là le principe de solidarité
intergénérationnelle nous sommes passés
de trois actifs pour un retraité à 1,7
actifs pour un retraité aujourd'hui cela
tient peut-être à des conditions et des
considérations sur la natalité ça tient
aussi à l'augmentation l'espérance de
vie ce qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
et nous savons ce sont là les
projections démographiques que en 2040
nous serons plutôt autour de 1,4 actifs
pour un retraité et avec le risque qu'en
2050 nous soyons à 1,2 actifs pour un
retraité c'est là l'explication la plus
importante à la fois à la nécessité de
la réforme que nous menons mais aussi
l'explication la plus importante au
déficit structurel que connaît notre
système si nous ne le réforme pas
puisque s'il y a moins d'actifs pour
financer des retraites évidemment cela
va être de nature agréé le système d'un
point de vue financier vous nous dites
est-ce que au travers de cette réforme
est plus largement mais pour les
questions plus larges peut-être qu'il y
aura d'autres débats pour y revenir vous
nous dites est-ce que vous pouvez
soutenir les questions de natalité nous
le faisons et dans ce débat sur la
réforme des retraites il y a un certain
nombre de mesures qui vont dans ce sens
le fait de faire en sorte que les
trimestres qui sont validés au titre de
l'assurance vieillesse pour les parents
au foyer qui concernent un million 900
000 femmes par an puis cette prise en
compte à la fois pour l'éligibilité au
dispositif de départ anticipe pour
carrière longue comme au dispositif
d'éligibilité à la retraite minimum
c'est une manière de faire en sorte de
protéger de mieux protéger les femmes en
l'occurrence et des trimestres dont elle
bénéficie j'entends mesdames et
messieurs les députés vous parlez de
natalité en général et j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire il y a l'instant
qu'il y aura d'autres sujets mais
permettez-moi de conclure monsieur le
député en ayant en tête les positions
que vous avez pu prendre par exemple sur
la loi relative à l'IVG l'objectif de
cette majorité sera de soutenir toutes
les familles toutes
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Xavier Breton
pour le groupe les républicains merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre et oui jamais la natalité
française n'a été aussi basse depuis
723000 c'est le nombre de naissances en
France en 2022 mais c'est surtout le
chiffre le plus bas depuis 75 ans le pic
de 800 000 naissances enregistrées entre
2006 et 2012 paraît bien lointain autre
chiffre inquiétant le taux de fécondité
qui mesure le nombre d'enfants en moyen
par femme est tombé à 1,8 nous sommes
bien loin du taux de 2,1 enfants qui
permet de stabiliser la population il
manque désormais chaque année 40 à 50
000 naissances pour assurer le
renouvellement des générations
madame la première médite nous devons
effectivement nous alerter de ces
chiffres et pourtant ces chiffres ne
sont pas étonnants depuis 10 ans en
effet des choix sont faits pour rompre
délibérément et par idéologie avec la
politique familiale de notre pays qui
faisait pourtant l'objet d'un consensus
politique très large depuis 10 ans sous
le mandat de François Hollande d'abord
sous le mandat d'Emmanuel Macron ensuite
tout objectif de soutien à la natalité
et systématiquement écarté et les
atteintes portées aux allocations
familiales au congé parental et au
quotient familial pénalise tout
particulièrement les familles des
classes moyennes et des classes
défavorisées alors madame la Première
ministre allez-vous réagir face à cette
baisse historique de l'indentalité
allez-vous enfin refaire du soutien à la
natalité une véritable priorité
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
combe ministre des Solidarités de des
personnes handicapées
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
breton vous avez raison comme vous nous
inquiétons des chiffres aujourd'hui de
la natalité dans notre dans notre pays
723000 naissances c'est un plus bas
historique pour autant avec une
fécondité d'un point 8 notre pays reste
l'un des pays d'Europe les plus les plus
féconds aujourd'hui mon rôle en tant que
ministre des familles c'est de favoriser
le rapprochement entre ce taux de
fécondité et celui du désir d'enfant de
notre pays qui est aux alentours de 2.4
par femme et on sait par ailleurs que ce
qui cause la plus grande différence
entre ce taux de fécondité et et le
désir d'enfant c'est la question de
l'équilibre entre vie personnelle et vie
professionnelle c'est pour ça que le
Président de la République tout au long
de sa campagne a promis de mettre en
place un service public de la petite
enfance pour favoriser justement la
natalité dans notre pays permettre de
réduire cet écart entre le taux de
fécondité et le taux de et le désir
d'enfant dans notre pays
ce service public de la petite enfance
j'ai lancé un débat dans le cadre du
Conseil national de la refondation pour
y travailler au niveau national avec les
associations d'élus avec les
associations familiales avec laquelle
Natura avec la Caisse nationale la
Caisse Nationale d'Assurance pardon avec
la CNAV avec la Caisse nationale des
allocations familiales je vais y arriver
pour pouvoir mettre en place ce service
public de la petite enfance créer d'ici
à 2030 200000 places d'accueil et
accompagner les collectivités à
développer cette offre c'est une
politique qui va permettre de mieux
équilibrer la vie familiale et la vie
professionnelle de renforcer l'équilibre
entre les femmes et les hommes et
surtout de lutter contre les inégalités
de destin dans la continuité des 1000
premiers jours pour accompagner les
enfants dans les trois premières années
de vie coucou monsieur le ministre
monsieur breton
il vous reste 19 secondes
les collectivités locales ne vous ont
pas attendu pour mettre en place des
services de petit enfant ils le font
déjà par contre là où vous avez des
responsabilités sérieux niveau fiscal
avec le plafond du quotient familial
c'est au niveau du budget famille avec
l'universalité le rétablissement de
l'universalité les allocations
familiales c'est avec un congé parental
qui sont pas idéologique mais qui soit
basé sur la réalité des familles c'est
là où on vous attend et qu'on attend que
vous preniez vos responsabilités
la parole est à Madame Brigitte Klinker
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire des
tâches chargée des affaires européennes
dimanche à Clermont marqué une nouvelle
étape dans la relation d'amitié qui lie
la France et l'Allemagne les cérémonies
organisées à la Sorbonne et ici dans
l'hémicycle ont été l'occasion de
manifester la force des liens qui nous
unissent 60 ans après la signature du
traité de l'Élysée après le traité de
l'Elysée qui était consacré à la
réconciliation le traité
d'Aix-la-Chapelle a posé le principe de
la convergence de manière générale mais
aussi explicitement dans le domaine
économique la France et l'Allemagne se
doivent donc d'harmoniser leur politique
l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande est au travail elle
veillera la réalisation des projets
inscrits au traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle et
aussi à l'harmonisation de la
transposition
directive européenne dans nos deux pays
aux côtés des initiatives
gouvernementales et citoyennes
l'Assemblée nationale et notre assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande ont plus
que jamais un rôle central à jouer comme
évoqué par le Président de la République
à la Sorbonne l'Allemagne et la France
doivent devenir pionnière pour la
refondation de notre Europe ensemble ils
nous reviendront d'adopter les mesures
adaptées pour ne pas subir les
événements mais au contraire pour agir
pour inverser leurs cours en ami et en
partenaire oui français allemand doivent
travailler ensemble pour renforcer le
rôle de l'Europe pour bâtir une
véritable souveraineté européenne madame
la ministre
quels sont les étapes concrètes à venir
les partenariats que vous allez
développer pour rendre cette coopération
franco-allemande toujours plus tangible
aux yeux de nos concitoyens je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Laurence bonne secrétaire des
tâches chargée de l'Europe merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Brigitte
klinkerte effectivement ce dimanche 22
janvier a pris un sens tout particulier
avec le retour de la guerre sur notre
continent il s'agissait donc d'abord de
célébrer la paix entre la France et
l'Allemagne symbolisé par le traité de
l'Élysée et ses 60 ans et d'ailleurs je
vous remercier tous les députés et
toutes les députés qui étaient présentes
qui contribuent à faire vivre l'amitié
franco-allemande de même que la
présidente de cette assemblée sa
déclaration commune avec celle de
l'Assemblée allemande
vous m'avez interrogé sur les
partenariats c'était également le
premier Conseil des ministres
franco-allemand avec les deux nouveaux
gouvernements et ils ont présenté une
feuille de route commune avec certains
projets j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
excuser la ministre Colona qui ne peut
être là aujourd'hui d'avoir des projets
sur la sécurité du continent avec le
soutien sans faille à l'Ukraine la
défense avec des projets comme le SCAP
l'industrie avec des projets notamment
pour la transition énergétique
avec le projet d'interconnexion
hydrogène h2mets d'effectivement
monsieur auquel l'Allemagne va
maintenant participer pour la sécurité
énergétique de notre continent mais
aussi la production de batterie les
programmes de recherche dans l'espace et
puis des projets de société je remercie
le ministre Clément bonne pour le
premier billet de train franco-allemand
pour les jeunes 60 000 en bénéficiant
gratuitement et un programme de jeunes
talents franco-allemand
parce que c'est la jeune génération
franco-allemande qui fera vivre cette
unité et la paix sur notre continent et
pas les dissension de son extrême droite
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Fabien Roussel pour le
groupe GDR
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Économie et des Finances
les hausses de factures de gaz et
d'électricité suscitent au moins autant
de colère que votre réforme des
retraites des locataires de HLM de
Saint-Amand-les-Eaux doivent payer des
régularisations de charges de 400 à 500
euros nos salaires deviennent hybrides
comme les voitures la moitié part dans
l'essence l'autre moitié dans
l'électricité des entreprises se
demandent comment elles paieront leurs
factures cette année plus 38000 euros
pour une boulangère de Rumegies plus 30
000 euros pour un boucher à Anzin des
communes des services publics exclus des
filets de sécurité réduisent leurs
investissements et tous les boucliers
tarifaires que vous mettez en place se
révèlent aussi insuffisant qu'il coûte
cher à nos finances publiques et les
Français les entreprises ne veulent pas
vivre survivre avec des aides mais vivre
de leur travail
pourtant nous avons tout en France grâce
à notre mix énergétique grâce au
nucléaire pour faire face à cette crise
quant à nos réserves de gaz elles sont
au plus haut
mais depuis que la France est soumise au
funestes lois de la libre concurrence
européenne les tarifs explosent nous
produisons de l'énergie à moins de 50
euros du mégawatt mais elle est revendu
5 à 10 fois plus cher à cause de la
spéculation Europe européenne et même
votre prix plafonné à 280 euros hors
taxes reste trop cher alors Monsieur le
Ministre la France est une grande nation
qui a subâtir son indépendance
énergétique avec notre proposition de
loi 110 députés de tout bord vous
demandent de rétablir des tarifs
réguliers pour tous entreprises communes
foyers avec des tarifs bas à prix
coûtant stable alors quand la France
va-t-elle enfin sortir l'électricité le
gaz de la spéculation européenne et
allez vous maintenir les tarifs régulés
du gaz au-delà du premier juillet merci
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Roussel je vais peut-être vous
surprendre mais mise à part évidemment
la remarque sur les retraites
je suis en plein accord avec ce que vous
venez de dire vous êtes pour
l'indépendance énergétique nous sommes
pour l'indépendance énergétique vous
êtes pour le renforcement de la filière
nucléaire nous sommes pour le
renforcement de la filière nucléaire
vous défendez les entreprises les
boulangers les bouchers nous défendons
les entreprises les boulangers les
bouchers les artisans les commerçants et
nous voulons les protéger contre
l'augmentation des factures c'est bien
pour cela que nous avons prévu de mettre
en place un bouclier tarifaire à 280
euros le mégawattheure maximum pour
toutes les traits de France en
particulier les boulangers qui subissent
cette double peine augmentation des
tarifs de l'électricité et augmentation
du prix des matières premières que ce
soit le beurre que ce soit la farine ou
que ce soit le pain au chocolat cher au
pain au chocolat ou chocolatine en
fonction de votre origine géographique
je voudrais simplement profiter de votre
question
pour lancer un appel solonel à toutes
les très petites entreprises qui ne se
sont pas déclarées comme très petites
entreprises auprès des fournisseurs
d'énergie il faut qu'elle le fasse dans
les jours qui viennent vous avez
aujourd'hui 1,5 millions de très petits
entreprises qui sont éligibles au tarifs
régulés il n'y a que la moitié d'entre
elles qui vont en bénéficier parce que
l'autre moitié ont choisi les tarifs de
marché et ne se sont pas déclarés comme
très petites entreprises auprès de leurs
fournisseurs vous avez 600 000
entreprises très petits entreprises
boulanger bouchées artisans qui ont
droit au bouclier ta référent 280 euros
elle doivent se déclarer comme TPE elles
doivent retirer le formulaire elles
doivent aller sur leur espace client
pour se déclarer comme très petites
entreprises et bénéficier de cette
protection dès les factures de février
elles verront qu'elles ont tout droit
pour les 2,1 millions de très petits
entreprises au bouclier tarifaires et à
la protection que légitimement monsieur
le président
réclamé pour notre petit entreprise
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin c'est
un tuile pour le groupe
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre du soft monsieur
le ministre qui veut de votre réforme
des retraites
il semblerait qu'il y ait la majorité
présidentielle tenue par les engagements
du candidat qu'il y ait Bruxelles qui
vous presse ardemment de prendre les
mesures il semblerait enfin que la
droite hésite et je rappelle à mes
collègues de droite sur ses bancs que 15
d'entre eux ont un mandat d'opposition
qu'il aura été confiée par des électeurs
contre des candidats la République en
marche ou la majorité présidentielle qui
veut de cette réforme les organisations
patronales unanimes qui vous applaudit
sur ce sujet les Français n'en veulent
pas 70% d'entre eux n'en veulent pas ils
étaient dans les rues à Foix à Auch à
Maubeuge à Saint-Quentin à Hirson Havane
et partout en France nous voulons vous
parler de l'emploi des seniors nous
voulons vous parler de l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes nous voulons
vous parler de la prime de vie chère
crée les conditions d'un débat apaisé
une seule mesure cristallise
l'incompréhension et la colère des
Français
cette mesure c'est le recul de l'âge
légal à 64 ans retirez-la et créons les
conditions d'un débat démocratique ici
pour améliorer le quotidien de nos
concitoyens monsieur le ministre la
balle est dans votre camp
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Olivier dusoft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député sainte-huile vous
nous dites mais pourquoi est-ce que vous
réformer une réforme parce que c'est
nécessaire
nous récemment parce que c'est
nécessaire parce que nous avons un
système je le répète pour la troisième
fois je crois dans cette séance nous
avons un système qui est
structurellement déficitaire vous le
savez parfaitement vous avez lu le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites le
système est déficitaire dès 2023 le
déficit se creuse en 2025 se creuse en
2030 se creuse en 2035 il se creuse en
2040 et nous considérons qu’équilibrer
le système est une responsabilité qui
nous incombe nous considérons aussi que
l'améliorer est aussi notre
responsabilité et donc ce que nous
faisons c'est à la fois améliorer sur
les thèmes que vous avez évoqué l'emploi
des seniors la pénibilité les carrières
longues la question d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes la question du
minimum de pension et en même temps nous
l'équilibrons ce sont les deux objectifs
que nous poursuivons
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur sainte-huile monsieur le
ministre on peut parler de la réforme et
de la l'équilibre du système mais
reconnaissons que cette réforme ce n'est
pas une réforme des retraites c'est une
réforme qui est finalement la réforme
des finances publiques vous n'interrogez
pas le capital vous interrogez pas le
patrimoine vous pensez sans doute de
bonne foi que vous faites preuve de
courage mais ce courage je l'assimile
moi à une surdité coupable vous menez
une procédure inflammable à un moment où
les Français sont à bout et je le dis
aux oppositions si nous sommes
intelligents ensemble dans cette
hémicycle nous ferons plier le
gouvernement
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député
c'est le député
que proposez-vous en réalité vous dites
vous-même qu'il y a un système qui était
équilibré vous dites qu'il faut que ce
système revienne à l'équilibre
qu'aurions-nous du faire baisser les
pensions c'est ce que vous proposez et
mettre à mal les retraités
augmenter la fiscalité revenir sur la
politique de l'emploi
augmenter les prélèvements obligatoires
qui sont à un niveau record et supprimer
les emplois entraver la marche vers Le
Pen emploi que vous proposez-vous est-ce
que vous proposez d'aller à la ruine de
laisser le système filet
[Musique]
vous avez écoulé votre temps de parole
merci monsieur le ministre je répète
monsieur le député à vous écouter il
aurait fallu baisser les retraites et
augmenter les impôts c'est le contraire
de ce que nous décidons nous croyons au
travail nous croyons à la croissance
nous croyons la prospérité nous croyons
en pleine emploi et nous croyons à des
bonnes retraites parce que ne pas le
faire c'est mettre en marche la machine
à décoque la machine à petite pension et
la machine à créer de la pauvreté
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Sabine pour le
groupe démocrate merci madame la
présidente madame la secrétaire d'État
aux Affaires européennes également
secrétaire général à la coopération
entre la France et l'Allemagne je peux
évidemment pas m'empêcher de parler des
60 ans du traité de l'Élysée pour moi
toujours un miracle la réconciliation
franco-allemande et un miracle après 40
ans en France je suis arrivé il y a 40
ans si vous me le permettez sans parler
français de pouvoir être aujourd'hui ici
et de prendre la parole sans que ça pose
plus de problèmes que ça et ça on a je
mesure dans ma vie le chemin parcouru et
je voudrais rappeler une autre date le 9
mai 1950 la le discours de Robert
Schuman anat fondateur qui a en réalité
permis cette réconciliation
franco-allemande et je n'ai jamais
compris pourquoi la France n'est pas
plus fière de ça c'est je pense qu'il y
a tendu la main à l'Allemagne avec
énormément d'audace et de vision nous
avons certes divergence mais nous avons
surtout aussi un socle commun nous
sommes attachés à l'état de droit à la
démocratie nous sommes derrière l'Union
européenne et nous soutenons sans faille
le peuple
ukrainien qui nous montre aussi
aujourd'hui une chose extrêmement
importante il n'y a pas de bonheur sans
liberté il n'y a pas de liberté sans
courage sans audace est-ce que nous
aujourd'hui on a encore cette audace et
aujourd'hui nous avons accordé ce statut
de candidat à l'Ukraine ça va être une
discussion très difficile entre nous
mais en réalité on en a besoin d'élargir
et on a besoin par contre aussi une
réforme institutionnelle de l'Union
européenne pour que l'on soit en
capacité d'agir madame la secrétaire
d'État avec votre homologue en allure
man vous avez mis en place un forum
d'experts hier vous êtes venu hier pour
parler justement des dispositions qu'on
peut prendre
pour vous donner un coup de pouce dans
cette union européenne qui doit faire
face à des défis extraordinaires
aujourd'hui
quels sont les démarches à suivre merci
je vous remercie mes chers collègues la
parole est à Laurence bonne secrétaire
d'État chargée de l'Europe
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente et Madame la
député effectivement parmi les projets
concrets qui ont été mises en œuvre dans
le cadre du 60e anniversaire du traité
de l'Élysée il y a la mise en place d'un
groupe d'experts indépendants français
et allemand pour réfléchir à l'évolution
des institutions européennes pour y
réfléchir pour trois raisons pour la
simplicité de son action l'efficacité et
la rapidité de son action aujourd'hui
pour la protection de ces valeurs et je
pense notamment à l'état de droit qui
est mené dans autant de pays à
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne qu'aux
frontières de l'Union européenne
c'est 12 experts français et allemands
rendront à l'automne 2023 des
propositions qui viseront à accélérer
simplifier et rendre plus efficace et
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne le
rapprocher des citoyens et étudier
comment la main tendue à l'Ukraine la
Moldavie la Géorgie les pays des Balkans
peut se transformer en une association
et préparer l'élargissement tout en
maintenant l'efficacité de l'Union
européenne je sais
cela fera du mal à certains autres mais
la sécurité dans notre continent passe
par là et la sauvegarde de nos valeurs
démocratiques aussi merci
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Hervé de l'épineau
pour le groupe rassemblement national
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier
du socle je crois que c'est votre
journée aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre
après l'abandon des politiques
familiales voilà la soumission à la
volonté Bruxelles Oise de baisser les
pensions de retraite et la promotion
d'une immigration de masque comme remède
à la baisse des cotisations sociales du
fait de la diminution du nombre d'actifs
vous êtes l'héritier assumé des
politiques
u NPS devenus lrem dans votre parcours
politique ressemble à un exercice de
godille parmi les dispositifs constitués
par vos prédécesseurs se trouvent
cependant un outil qui mérite notre
attention le fond de réserve des
retraites le F RR ce dispositif créé par
le gouvernement Jospin à l'aube des
années 2000 ce qui prouve que les
socialistes sont capables de faire
parfois des choses utiles de
bénitialement permettre de soutenir
notre régime des retraites face au choc
générationnel du pepy-boom un dispositif
plutôt bien pensé qui n'aura en réalité
durée que 10 ans si à son élaboration
l'objectif était de constituer une
réserve de 150 milliards de dépôts il a
péniblement atteint 36 milliards en 2010
c'est à cette époque que votre nouveau
compagnon de route Éric verse avait cru
bon dans son projet de réforme des
retraites de mettre fin aux abondements
de l'État dans ce fond lui préférant un
unique décaissement au profit de la
caisse d'amortissement de la dette
sociale la Cadès la conséquence directe
de ce choix a été l'assèchement du Fonds
de réserve des retraites et l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 n'a pas
inversé la tendance baissière puisqu'il
ne représentait plus aujourd'hui que
21,5 milliards d'euros
si l'on en croit le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale aura
purée son passif aux alentours de 2030
de sorte que le Fonds de réserve des
retraites devrait retrouver son objet
initial compenser le déficit des
retraites pas de la dette sociale je me
permets donc de vous rappeler au bon mot
d'Émile de Girardin gouverner ses
prévoir monsieur le ministre
Monsieur Olivier du Sapt ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député vous terminez au-delà
des mots que je n'ose qualifier
d'outrancier parce que je crains qui
n'est pas dépensé votre passe qui n'est
pas dépassé votre pensée en réalité mais
vous vous terminez en disant gouverner
ces prévoir c'est ce que nous faisons
c'est ce que nous faisons face à un
système qui est en déficit chronique
nous prenons les mesures pour à la fois
améliorer ce système et permettre sa
pérennité permettre sa périphériter pour
nos enfants permettre sa pérennité pour
nos petits-enfants permettre de garantir
le système par répartition qui est un
des joyaux de la solidarité
intergénérationnelle le projet que vous
avez présenté défendu pendant l'élection
présidentielle projet illisible projet
inefficace coûterait 10 milliards
d'euros finances publiques il n'y a rien
de mal il n'y a rien de sale amener une
réforme qui améliore les droits et qui
rétablit les comptes publics comme
ancien ministre en charge des comptes
publics je sais trop l'importance du
rétablissement et la des comptes publics
pour la souveraineté de notre passion si
vous êtes comme vous le prétendez
parfois attachez la souveraineté vous
devriez aussi parfois savoir accompagner
les efforts de celles et ceux qui la
garantissent
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien Rome
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie sur
les réseaux sociaux il y a encore un
instant vous invitiez à nos PME nos TPE
nos boulangers en particulier à
télécharger un formulaire pour
bénéficier du bouclier tarifaire
pourquoi parce que entre le producteur
et l'interrupteur c'est un fracas
d'unchevêtrement confus organisant un
marché volatile où les prix sont sans
lien avec la production mais totalement
avec la spéculation mais les Français
les françaises veulent vivre de leur
travail et non de formulaire rocher de
chaque cadeau ou de boucliers percés
pourtant
il existe une solution ordonnée
protectrice pour nos TPE nos PME nos
entreprises de taille intermédiaires nos
artisans nos commerçants et l'ensemble
des Français les tarifs réglementés de
la vente de l'électricité des connectés
du marché
en commission des finances avec mes
collègues nous vous avions alerté dès
l'automne sur l'impact de l'inflation
pour les commerçants et les artisans
mais vous avez préféré attendre cet
hiver en découvrant l'impact de la
volatilité des prix les citoyens les
collectivités mais aussi la première
entreprise de France ont tous été
convaincus d'une évidence il faut un
retour des tarifs réglementés pour cela
il faut sortir du marché européen de
l'électricité comme l'a fait le
gouvernement espagnol et qu'il va
continuer à le faire alors en
rétablissement des tarifs réglementés de
vente de l'électricité qui rémunère
uniquement le coût de production du
transport et de la commercialisation on
rétabli des préjudes comment combien de
temps allez-vous attendre encore donc
quand allez-vous mettre enfin un terme à
la concurrence du marché de l'énergie
alors que c'est bien une nécessité
absolue pour le concitoyen et entreprise
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
Sébastien Rome bonjour
les ménages en France bref il est mieux
protégés de tous les ménages européens
grâce au bouclier tarifaires que nous
avons mis en place chez l'électricité
comme sur le gaz depuis deux ans comme
aucun autre pays européen n'a su le
faire c'est ce qui nous permet d'avoir
monsieur Sébastien Rome le taux
d'inflation parmi les plus bas de tous
les pays de la zone euro depuis deux ans
parce que nous avons protégé massivement
nos compatriotes pour les très petites
entreprises mais je vais vous rejoindre
peut-être pour une fois une des rares
fois je vous redis que les tarifs
réguliers de vente bénéficient à 1,5
millions de très petites entreprises
mais que c'est très petites entreprises
pour en bénéficier doivent se déclarer
auprès de leurs fournisseur d'énergie si
elles ne l'ont pas fait il y en a la
moitié à peu près d'entre elles qui
l'ont fait l'autre moitié qui n'a pas
encore fait je renouvelle mon appel
solonel à toutes les très petites
entreprises moins de 10 salariés moins
de 2 millions euros de chiffre
d'affaires est-ce que
vous pouvez être non mais c'est
insupportable
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
de la nupesse
on aimerait pouvoir s'adresser aux
Français sur que nous interrompiez sans
cesse quand on leur rapporte des
réponses alors qu'elles sont à leurs
interrogations et à leurs angoisses
[Applaudissements]
je vous redis que toutes les très
petites entreprises pour qu'elles
bénéficient des tarifs réguliers de
vente et qu'elle puisse bénéficier du
bouclier que la demande de la première
ministre à la demande du Président de la
République nous avons mis en place pas
plus de 280 euros le Mégane wher le 1,5
millions de TPE éligibles TRV les 2,1
millions de très petites entreprises qui
ont moins de 10 salariés
mais pouvez-vous écouter une seconde la
réponse que nous faisons à nos
compatriotes qui sont inquiets pour les
tarifs de l'électricité
ils doivent aller se déclarer
se déclarer comme très petite entreprise
auprès de def auprès de l'énergie auprès
d'engie auprès de tous les fournisseurs
merci monsieur le ministre je regrette
de pas pouvoir donner des réponses
complètes aux Français parce que les
députés de la nupesse nous empêchent de
nous exprimer correctement
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Julien dive
pour le groupe les républicains
merci Madame la Président je voudrais
associer à ma question Valérie Bazin
malgrat 200 millions d'euros ce sont les
pertes de rendement estimées par les
betteraviers à la suite de l'épidémie de
la jaunisse qui a décimé les hectares
entiers de culture en 2020 alors que
cette année noir
assemblée appartenir au passé jeudi 19
janvier 2023 la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne on a décidé autrement
alors en effet jugé illégal les
dérogations accordées aux agriculteurs
pour l'usage de néonicotinoïdes en
enrobage de semences cette décision est
un véritable coup de massue pour la
filière betterave sucre quelques
semaines avant les semis de la campagne
2023 2024 les producteurs sont
aujourd'hui confrontés à une réalité
agronomique qui est à contre-courant des
décisions prises par la cgue alors que
cela fait des semaines que l'on entend
le ministre de la transition écologique
se positionner contre les betteraviers
il a fallu s’est arrêté brutal pour que
nous soyons obligés d'agir dans
l'urgence et sortir de cet impasse
monsieur le ministre agriculture vous
proposez un plan d'action en soutien à
la filière mais il nous faut des
engagements concrets et durable le plan
national de recherche et d'innovation
que vous mentionnez ne demande pas
seulement de l'argent mais aussi du
temps et le temps de nos 24000
betteraviers et compter aussi vous
évoquez dans ce plan d'action un
accompagnement financier mais nos
producteurs de pommes de terre féculents
se souviennent encore de ses promesses
non tenues alors ou comptez-vous
chercher ces fonds quels en sont les
règles avec ou sans plafond avec ou sans
franchise en dehors des règles des
minimis aujourd'hui aucun pays membres
ne peut déroger à l'interdiction des nni
enrobés sur des graines de betteraves
sauf l'Allemagne deuxième producteur de
betterave à sucre en Europe après la
France qui feinte cette étape arrêtée en
utilisant des insecticides pulvérisés
que vous interdisez en France les mêmes
règles dont lieu doivent s'appliquer
pour tous monsieur le ministre
comptez-vous monter au créneau pour
proposer l'instauration des mêmes règles
du jeu au sein de l'Union européenne
pour préserver une autre souveraineté
agricole et permettent aux agriculteurs
français de fournir le sucre le
bioéthanol le gel hydruque
hydroalcoolique dont nous avons besoin
chaque jour merci beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Julien dit merci d'être question vous
connaissez bien le sujet d'abord parce
que vous êtes dans un département qui
est concerné par ailleurs parce que vous
travaillez sur cette question y compris
depuis le vote de la loi sur le régime
duquel nous sommes qui avaient permis la
dérogation sur l'enrobage des semences
c'était bien ça qui était prévu et vous
l'avez rappelé d'une certaine façon il
était prévu que nous sortions en trois
ans par une dérogation sur simplement
l'enrobage des semences et la décision
de la Cour de justice vient interrompre
le processus dans lequel nous étions
lancés et ça vient durement interrompre
le processus pourquoi parce que nous
attendions une troisième année
d'expérimentation et c'est ce qui avait
été décidé par le gouvernement c'était
lancer la troisième année
d'expérimentation pour enfin valider les
solutions parce que on a besoin c'est
pas de la magie les solutions les
solutions c'est de la recherche du temps
et d'innovation qu'il faut mettre en
oeuvre trois éléments de réponse
première élément ça me permet d'ailleurs
de répondre à lise-mania qui m'avait
interrogé évidemment la décision de la
Cour de justice va s'appliquer à
l'ensemble des des parlements et des
pays européens deuxième élément et donc
s'il y avait un besoin nous activons et
d'ailleurs c'est le processus dans
lequel on va nous activerons est-ce
qu'on appelle la clause de sauvegarde et
donc pour éviter que les distorsions de
secret à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne ça c'est sur les enrobages
deuxième élément je le dis par rapport à
l'engagement vous me demandez par
rapport à la filière évidemment c'est un
engagement qui sera tenu de couverture
juridique tout à l'heure de
l'intégralité des pertes sur la jaunisse
je rappelle et vous le savez aussi bien
que moi ça c'est pour l'urgence parce
qu'on a besoin de répondre en urgence au
planteur parce que la décision arrive au
moment où les décisions de plantations
devaient se faire et donc on a besoin de
dire ça dès à présent au planteur puis
deuxième élément c'est de continuer à
prolonger la recherche à la fois sur les
itinéraires techniques plus classiques
et par ailleurs au travers du pnli je
sais vous avez raison c'est long mais il
n'y a pas d'autre choix et de toute
façon nous étions dans la tendance
d'interdire à l'issue les
néonicotinoïdes puisque c'est la loi qui
avait été volée à l'Assemblée nationale
et au Sénat sous une forme de compromis
avec la filière voilà le travail que
nous avons à faire
voilà le travail que nous avons à faire
monsieur le député je compte sur nous
tous pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions envoyer ces messages à la
filière ceux du court terme et si du
moyen à long terme parce que comme vous
l'avez dit c'est une filière très
importante pour la France et cette
filière qui compte beaucoup en termes de
souveraineté merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Michel
perron pour le groupe Renaissance madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre Marc
féno mes chers collègues la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne a rendu
une décision de bannir l'hétérogation au
nicotinoïdes suite à l'interdiction des
nni en 2018 et une épidémie de jaunisses
qui avait décimé les parcelles de
betterave sucrière c'est toute une
filière qui était en danger nous avions
donc mis en place une dérogation qui
devait courir jusqu'au mois de juillet
2023 et des moyens massifs pour la
recherche afin de laisser le temps pour
trouver une alternative viable en clair
pas d'interdiction sans solution j'ai
rencontré les agriculteurs de
Seine-et-Marne ce vendredi suite à la
décision de la CGE leur inquiétude est
forte
réel cette décision est brutale pour nos
agriculteurs en pleine campagne de
semences brutal quand d'autres pays
européens sont bien moins respectueux de
l'environnement et que les recherches
sont toujours en cours nos agriculteurs
ont toujours fait preuve de soutien
envers ces recherches d'alternatives je
souhaite assurer que le groupe
Renaissance est aux côtés des
agriculteurs et partage leurs
inquiétudes c'est aujourd'hui 45000
emplois de la filière française qui sont
menacées suite à cette décision c'est un
enjeu plus large relatif à notre
souveraineté alimentaire face au pays
hors de l'Union Européenne qui n'ont pas
ce type d'interdiction il existe un vrai
risque d'abandon de la part des
agriculteurs de cette culture car elle
serait jugée trop peu rentable les
solutions de remplacement sont bien
avancées mais ne sont pour leur pas
assez satisfaisante les agriculteurs ont
besoin de signes forts de notre part
monsieur le ministre
quelles sont les solutions à court terme
pour les agriculteurs dont les semences
sont en cours
seront les garanties apportées en
soutien aux agriculteurs et à la
recherche des solutions alternatives
merci je vous remercie ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur Marc
phénoministre de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci Madame la
dépendance maladie la présidente Madame
et Messieurs les Députés madame la
député Péron merci de votre question qui
viendra compléter utilement en tout cas
je l'espère par ma réponse les questions
qui m'ont été posées par vos collègues
vous êtes dans un département qui est
éminemment concerné par ce sujet d'abord
parce que c'est un département dont on
connaît l'importance en termes de
betteraves de production de bêtave et
deuxièmement parce que c'est l'un des
départements qui a été le plus touché
par les épisodes de Johnny ce contenu à
la fois du dérèglement climatique et
donc de l'impact que ça peut avoir sur
la prolifération des pucerons qui sont
liés à la jaunisse je ne reviens pas sur
ce que j'ai dit mais évidemment le
gouvernement sera au rendez-vous il a
été comme il a été au rendez-vous pour
la filière viticole comme elle a été en
rendez-vous sur la filière aviaire comme
il a été rendez-vous sur la filière
pensée nous sommes au rendez-vous parce
que nous voulons préserver la
souveraineté alimentaire de notre pays
et donc nous avons besoin de conforter
le monde agricole dans ce domaine voilà
les éléments factuels premier élément
donc un plan d'accompagnement sur 2023
qui puisse couvrir le risque de perte de
récolte sur la jaunisse deuxième élément
c'est la recherche il me semble que la
recherche est un élément très important
et fondamental en particulier la voix il
y a les plans de campagne mais la voie
la plus prometteuse sans doute et la
recherche au travers des semences et
nous avons besoin d'accompagner plus
avant j'en parlais hier avec les
semenciers les techniques de semences
qui permettront les techniques de
recherche qui permettront d'avoir des
semences qui seront des betteraves
résistantes à la jaunisse que c'est
quand même sans doute le meilleur moyen
pour faire face à cela deuxième élément
je dis sur la question industrielle je
dis d'ailleurs sous le regard de mon
collègue Lescure on aura besoin de
travailler avec la filière pour assurer
que les outils industriels sont
préservés parce qu'évidemment sans
oublier industriel il y a pas de
planteur et sans planteur il y a pas
d'outils industriels et donc ça c'est un
élément de préoccupation qui est éminent
en particulier dans le département qui
est le vôtre vous le savez aussi bien
que moi et puis troisième élément c'est
de continuer à déployer nos dispositifs
de recherche et puis nous permettrait
une réflexion globale
tous les sujets de cette nature en
termes de produits phytop phytosanitaire
il faut qu'on les pose au niveau
européen
dès lors qu'on commence à avoir des
dispositifs qui sont différents en
France que dans les autres prix on crée
les conditions d'une distorsion qui
n'est pas acceptable c'est donc tout le
combat que nous menons à la fois pour
être sur la tendance de réduction des
produits phytosanitaires mais que le
faisions au niveau européen et pas
ailleurs merci à vous je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
madame Béatrice Descamps pour le groupe
liotte
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame Charlotte cobel
secrétaire d'État chargés de l'enfance
madame la ministre la semaine dernière
était votée dans cette hémicycle la
création d'un dispositif d'aide
d'urgence à destination des victimes de
violences conjugales et un très
familiales ces violences conjugales des
conséquences dramatiques sur les enfants
des violences qui créent des
traumatismes profonds auxquels souvent
lourdes ce qui est d'ailleurs mis en
avant depuis longtemps par la
littérature scientifique et la prise de
conscience des pouvoirs publics et elle
réelle mais relativement récente en
témoigne de nombreux travaux
législatives le Grenelle de 2018 sur les
violences conjugales un quant à lui
enfin donner une place aux enfants je
pense également aux actions engagées par
de nombreux conseils départementaux
comme celui du département du Nord
pourtant les chiffres actuels restent
dramatiques 398
000 enfants
42% d'entre eux ont moins de 6 ans pire
encore parmi les femmes victimes 70%
d'entre elles ont été témoins de rangs
durant leur propre enfance de violence
conjugales qui ont altéré leur
discernement de comportement face à ces
violences d'où l'indispensable nécessité
d'agir dès l'enfance agir le plus tôt
possible madame la ministre pour
accompagner ses enfants mais aussi de
nombreux adultes car la réponse n'est
pas toujours judiciaire nous manquons
aujourd'hui cruellement de moyens
humains professionnels de santé
psychologue psychiatre pédopsychiatre
éducateur comment le gouvernement
envisage-t-il de faire face à ce constat
dramatique accentué par les inégalités
territoriales et de tenter de permettre
à ces personnes à ses enfants de
retrouver une vie normal tant que faire
ce peu je vous remercie ma chère
collègues la parole
est à
Charlotte cobel secrétaire détacha
chargé de l'enfance madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée oui les violences commises dans
le saint dans le sein de la famille
provoque des dommages extrêmement
importants pour nos enfants oui
aujourd'hui nous n'arrivons pas à casser
la chaîne de violence au sein des
familles elle se reproduisent oui il
faut être tous mobilisés pour casser
cette chaîne de violence c'est d'abord
la mobilisation de Isabelle ROM et de
l'ensemble des députés et des sénateurs
de l'ensemble du département
engagés dans le Grenelle des violences
faites aux femmes c'est essentiel et
l'adoption la semaine dernière de cette
aide d'urgence est tout à fait
fondamentale pour les femmes et bien sûr
pour les enfants qui les ont
accompagnent oui il faut améliorer
encore la chaîne de traitement poli
gendarmerie justice et le ministre de la
Justice le ministre de l'Intérieur s'y
attelle pour non seulement prendre en
compte la parole des femmes mais prendre
encore mieux rendre compte la parole des
enfants oui la place de l'enfant dans le
dispositif judiciaire le garde des sceau
a déjà pris des mesures il entend en
prendre d'autres encore la première ça a
été de reconnaître ses enfants comme
victime systématiquement d'autre part
ces données une place aux parents
judiciaire c'est-à-dire à cette
administrateur administrateur adoc qui
doit accompagner l'enfant dans le
processus pénal et enfin bien sûr c'est
prendre en compte la le préjudice des
enfants évidemment c'est entendre la
parole dans les yeux à Pep après il faut
accompagner ses enfants auprès des
départements les départements s'y
attelent autant qu'ils le peuvent avec
les associations des moyens sont à
disposition il faut les renforcer et
surtout il faut coordonner l'action mais
tout ça nous le ferons mais nous devons
le faire avec tous les adultes de ce
pays et les familles il faut que tout le
monde prenne caution de cette violence
et ils mettent fin merci madame la
députée d'alerter encore sur cette
urgence sociétale
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Fabrice le vigoureux pour le
groupe Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Pape Ndiaye ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
ministre je souhaite aujourd'hui vous
interroger sur les carrières
enseignantes sur la considération que
nous devons à toutes ces femmes et ces
hommes qui se sont engagés dans cette
mission si noble si essentielle si
fondamental pour l'avenir de notre pays
celle de transmettre des savoirs des
savoir-faire et de plus en plus des
savoir-être à nos enfants de la
maternelle au lycée celle de former des
citoyens éclairés capables de voir dans
notre démocratie un bien précieux et de
laisser toutes les opinions s'exprimer
dès lors qu'elles le font sans haine
celle de respecter chacun quel que soit
son origine sa couleur de peau son
orientation sexuelle sa religion celle
de donner à chaque enfant les clés pour
trouver sa voie et les moyens de
s'épanouir
celle d'enseigner quelle incroyable
formidable et exigeante mission le
budget de l'Éducation nationale est le
premier budget de notre nation près de
60 milliards d'euros ce budget il a
augmenté de 21% depuis 2017 a un rythme
deux fois plus soutenu que lors du
quinquennat socialiste précédent ce qui
devrait en inviter certains dans cette
émission la cultiver un peu d'humilité
sur le sujet monsieur le ministre vous
avez voulu en 2023 que l'augmentation
très significative du budget de votre
ministère soit en grande partie dédiée à
la revalorisation des carrières des
enseignants qu'aucun ne démarre à moins
de 2000 euros net et qu'en moyenne ces
enseignées ces enseignants bénéficient
d'une hausse de leur rémunération de 10%
à compter de la prochaine rentrée et
même jusqu'à 20% s'il s'engage sur des
missions complémentaires que beaucoup
assument déjà sans contrepartie
financière c'est un grand pas l'amorce
d'un grand rattrapage après quatre
décennies de l'an et sournois
affaissement des rémunérations
faisant ça pour que nos meilleurs
étudiants reconsidèrent l'enseignement
comme une voix attractive alors Monsieur
le Ministre pouvez-vous nous repréciser
votre feuille de route pour mieux
reconnaître le métier d'enseignant si
crucial pour l'avenir de notre pays je
vous remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur pas
Penda et ministre
si on national et de la jeunesse merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
le vigoureux vous l'avez dit la question
de l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
est une priorité du gouvernement en
témoigne l'augmentation
importante du budget de l'Éducation
nationale cette année plus 6,5%
l'engagement quotidien des enseignants
doit être mieux reconnu c'est
incontestable j'ai ouvert la semaine
passée avec les organisations syndicales
représentatives le cycle de concertation
sur l'attractivité et la revalorisation
du métier d'enseignant et nous avons
ouvert aujourd'hui les concertations
techniques pour définir précisément dans
le respect du dialogue social les
mesures qui viendront contribuer à
restaurer l'attractivité du métier par
une rémunération à hauteur de
l'engagement des enseignants cette
revalorisation elle porte sur deux
dimensions d'abord une revalorisation
qu'on appelle une revalorisation socle
ça signifie qu'elle concernera dès la
rentrée 2023 le plus grand nombre
possible d'enseignants j'ai parlé de la
des enseignants en première moitié de
carrière mais il est possible aussi que
les enseignants en seconde moitié de
carrière soit concernés c'est un des
points de la concertation deuxièmement
ça c'est 10% d'augmentation en moyenne
pour les enseignants deuxièmement une
revalorisation liée à l'exercice de
nouvelles missions ceux des enseignants
qui s'engageront dans ces nouvelles
missions que nous allons définir en
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales recevront une augmentation
supplémentaire de 10% pour un total de
20% pour les enseignants concernés
l'objectif c'est de conclure la
concertation au mois de mars afin de
mettre en œuvre ces mesures pour le
premier septembre 2023 cet engagement du
gouvernement il traduit bien
notre considération pour les professeurs
et le fait que les professeurs doivent
être de mieux payé mieux traiter et
c'est précisément ce que nous allons
faire
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Lionel Tivoli pour
le rassemblement national
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
ministre il est désormais révolu le
temps ou la France était cette nation
puissante et surtout indépendante depuis
30 ans maintenant les prétendus élite
qui ont gouverné notre pays ont dilapidé
l'ensemble de nos intérêts stratégiques
majeurs au profit de la Commission
européenne les gouvernements successifs
n'ont conduit notre pays car ruine et
désastre faisant de l'ancienne Première
nation européenne un pays désormais sous
la tutelle de l'Union européenne nous
sommes asservis à l'Union européenne
lorsqu'encore aujourd'hui à l'heure nous
parlons nous adhérons au marché européen
de l'électricité aberration économique
et écologique qui consiste à vendre
notre énergie nucléaire décarbonée à
49,50 € pays européens pour en retour
acheter une énergie produite à partir du
gaz et de charbon à des prix exorbitants
une moyenne de 125 euros ces derniers
jours nous sommes asservis à l'un
européenne lorsque la semaine dernière
encore la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne au nom de la primauté du
droit communautaire sur les droits
nationaux annoncé l'interdiction des
néonicotinoïdes pour les agriculteurs
européens alors même que des produits
agricoles venant de notre bout du monde
qui entre dans l'Union à cause des
traités de libre-échange se vendent et
se consomme chaque jour sur notre marché
commun alors même qu'ils ont été traités
avec ses produits interdits dans l'Union
comment allez-vous expliquer à ceux qui
cultivent des betteraves qui ne pourront
plus utiliser des néonicotinoïdes
pourtant obligatoire qu'ils ne pourront
plus les utiliser pour ne pas tuer des
abeilles avec une butine pas sur la
betterave l'inquiétude des Français face
à la crise énergétique et la hausse de
l'inflation que la Banque centrale
européenne ne maîtrise plus le
gouvernement a seulement jugé bon
d'attribuer des chèques énergies un peu
comme une aumône ne boulangers nos
industries nos TPE nos tmpme sont à
l'agonie les Français pèsent à se
chauffer nos agriculteurs suivent
subissent au fil des décisions une
concurrence de plus en plus déloyale
monsieur le ministre quand
concentrez-vous donc de céder aux
sirènes de Bruxelles et à partir de
quand commencerez-vous à vous soucier
des intérêts des Français seul maître
légitime de leur destin merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Roland Lescure
ministre délégués chargés de l'industrie
merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
Tivoli vous avez comme souvent mélangé
tout dans votre question si ce n'est une
seule chose vous racontez n'importe quoi
sur l'Europe
c'est qu'évidemment il faudrait en
sortir la réalité c'est que sur le
marché de l'énergie monsieur le député
Tivoli s'il y avait pas eu le marché de
l'énergie il y a quelques semaines nous
n'aurions pas eu assez d'électricité
pour éclairer cette salle puisque vous
le saviez à l'époque nous apportions de
l'électricité allemande la réalité
monsieur le député c'est que personne en
Europe aujourd'hui ne paye son
électricité à 49,50 € sauf une partie
des industriels français et des
consommateurs français qui grâce au
dispositif de la reine dont vous vous
désintéressez permet à nos industriels
et à nos ménages de bénéficier d'une
facture d'énergie inférieure à la
plupart des autres pays européens
la réalité c'est que ça fait des années
et je me permets de le dire ainsi que
vous faites votre beurre sur les
difficultés économiques et sociales des
entreprises et des ménages français et
la réalité c'est que pendant que vous
nourrissez des difficultés des autres
nous sommes à leur côté Olivia Grégoire
et son équipe a reçu les boulangers hier
le ministre de l'Agriculture est au côté
des producteurs de betteraves nous les
accompagnons dans ces moments difficiles
vous ne faites qu'une chose sauter comme
un cabri en disant sortons de l'Europe
sortons de l'Europe nous y sommes et
nous la changeons merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur David Riemann
pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la Première ministre alors
qu'une autre réforme des retraites est
possible par des mesures hautes que le
décalage de l'âge légal que conjugue à
la réforme de l'assurance chômage elle
précarisera les travailleurs seniors que
votre propre ministre des Relations avec
le Parlement reconnu que les femmes
seront les premières pénalisés par le
report de l'âge légal vous vous obstinez
à poursuivre tête baissée et RVC une
réforme injuste socialement et
inefficace économiquement il semblerait
donc que la politique de l'autruche ne
s'applique pas qu'à nous les peu nous
les rien nous les chiens nous les
maigres nous les maigre noir qui
n'appartient guère plus même cette odeur
blem destructure anciens madame la
Première ministre comment se fait-il que
77 ans après la départementalisation des
vieilles colonies sans se rétablir un
principe d'égalité avec l'Hexagone ce
point de Léon Banton Damas reste criant
d'actualité pourriez-vous m'expliquer
comment cette réforme pourrait
s'appliquer à nos territoires ou la
majorité de la population vit en dessous
des seuils de pauvreté ou notre réalité
est celle des vies active fragmentés oui
d'ores et déjà appliqué une politique à
deux vitesses une un film de vie chère
pour les fonctionnaires c'est oui mais
explique majoré pour ne pas que vous
précarisez ces noms de l'élaboration de
la loi vous regardez en l'air et ignorer
notre histoire nos traditions nos
réalités pensez-vous réellement aucune
telle réforme répondent à l'urgence que
traverse les Français et les Français
j'aimerais terminer en paraphrasant Aimé
Césaire dans l'actualité des propos
traduit l'inertie des politiques menées
depuis la départementalisation de nos
territoires compte donc ça sera nous
d'être le jouet sans mon carnaval des
autres ministres exécutif parlementaire
sachez-le nous nous continuerons plus
d'assister à la politique des autres
merci je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail
du plein emploi et de l'insertion
merci à madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député riman la dernière fois que j'ai
entendu citer Lyon contre la masse dans
cette hémistice c'est Christiane Taubira
à l'occasion de l'examen du texte sur
l'ouverture du mariage au coupe de même
sexe
et je suis toujours à gauche monsieur
Lucas vous vous êtes passés à l'extrême
gauche c'est la différence
nous sommes le seul député bien
conscient des difficultés rencontrées
par les territoires d'outre-mer mais je
voudrais simplement vous dire Monsieur
le Député qu'il y a trois sujets qui me
viennent à l'esprit quand vous évoquez
les territoires d'outre-mer autour de la
question des retraites premier sujet
c'est que nous avons encore du travail
et je pense que le président Chassaigne
confirmera cette affirmation pour faire
en sorte que les partenaires sociaux se
saisissent dans un certain nombre de
territoires d'outre-mer de la nécessité
d'élargir la couverture agir Carco
instant de salariés notamment la filière
agricole je pense à deux départements
qui ne sont pas encore couverts nous
avons aussi un travail pour achever des
périodes de convergence je pense à
Mayotte et puis votre question permet de
souligner un troisième point qui est
certainement le fruit de l'histoire le
fruit de l'histoire économique et social
de ces territoires vous nous dites votre
réforme va trop loin vous ne devriez pas
relever là je n'ai pas il y a des
territoires dans la République pour
lesquels l'application de cette réforme
est peut-être je peut-être une
modification moins importante dans la
vie quotidienne lorsqu'on regarde là
effectivement de départ non pas l'âge
légal d'ouverture des droits mais là
j'effectif nous constatons qu'en Guyane
en Martinique en Guadeloupe nous sommes
déjà entre 64 ans et demi et 65 ans je
ne dis pas que c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce que c'est le témoignage parfois de
carrière hachée mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que nous veillerons dans
ces territoires comme ailleurs est-ce
que la réforme s'applique le plus
justement possible je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur Riemann
oui juste une petite un rappel madame la
Première ministre suite à notre entrée
parlementaire en Guyane début de ce mois
nous avons envoyé un courrier pour une
rencontre assez rapide pour comparer
effectivement un certain nombre de
choses on n'a pas encore eu de réponse
de votre part on attend toujours je vous
remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Lionel Royer
Perrot pour le groupe Renaissance
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
Armées et j'y associe le président
Thomas gassiou ainsi que mes collègues
Mounir bellamyti et Yannick chenevard
monsieur le ministre vous le savez mieux
que quiconque nos armées on parle passé
était trop longtemps négligé pour ne pas
dire abîmé trop d'espoir déçu par des
lois de programmation militaire amputées
de leurs ambitions initiales avec pour
conséquence des capacités militaires
dégradées en 2018 la majorité
présidentielle a adopté une loi de
programmation militaire de réparation
qui fait rarissime dans l'histoire a été
intégralement respecté et exécuté dans
un monde incertain aux menaces hybrides
et évolutives la France devait se doter
d'une nouvelle votre programmation
militaire ambitieuse qui accompagne la
transformation de nos armées et s'adapte
aux nouveaux contextes géo stratégiques
le président de la République a annoncé
la semaine dernière un effort budgétaire
sans équivalent de 413 milliards d'euros
413 milliards d'euros pour permettre à
la France de rester une puissance
militaire mondiale
413 milliards d'euros pour assurer la
sécurité des Français et garantir la
protection de notre pays
413 milliards d'euros pour adapter nos
armées aux nouvelles menaces mais aussi
pour consolider notre dissuasion
nucléaire 413 milliards d'euros enfin
pour mieux équiper nos filles et fils de
France et pour venir en soutien à nos
forces armées car oui mes chers
collègues cet effort consenti par la
nation nous le leur devons aussi
Monsieur le Ministre alors que vous
allez être auditionné à 17 heures par la
Commission de la Défense nationale et
des forces armées pouvez-vous nous
indiquer en quoi cette historique
constitue un effort politique
budgétaire militaires et technologique
inédits je vous en remercie
[Applaudissements]
ministre des Armées
monsieur le député vous êtes revenu
évidemment sur les efforts précédents de
de réparation désormais nous sommes
malheureusement si j'ose dire dans une
séquence différente ou c'est loi de
programmation doivent définir un format
d'armée ce format d'armée doit nous
permettre de répondre à des menaces
certaines menaces sont bien connues
anciennes compétition entre les grandes
puissances proliférations terrorisme
malheureusement dont on ne parle plus
assez et malheureusement aussi un champ
désormais nouveau d'hybridité de
détournement à des fins militaires
d'objets civils des espaces nouveaux de
conflictualité ou de confrontation c'est
vrai défense sous-marins c'est vrai du
cyber c'est vrai du spatial et
d'ailleurs quand on interroge la somme
413 milliards d'euros il faut rappeler
que ces nouveaux espaces nécessitent des
sauts technologiques importants et qui
sont particulièrement coûteux c'est donc
un défi qui s'impose à nous à la nation
française tout entière pour les années
qui viennent de rester dans le match des
compétitions en tout cas de capables de
tenir une compétition avec d'autres
puissances ou d'autres menaces étant
entendu bien sûr que notre format
d'armée purement défensif et s'inscrit
aussi pour défendre les valeurs qui sont
celles des valeurs de la République
alors le président de la République a
donné le cadre l'ambition la stratégie
les éléments aussi qui concernent nos
alliances sur lequel aussi il faudra que
les différentes sensibilités politiques
peut-être reviennent sur ce sujet pour
clarifier aussi dans quel contexte la
France en temps évoluer avec son armée
et désormais va s'ouvrir une nouvelle
période de consultation de notre base
industrielle et technologique de défense
parce que le modèle d'armée comprend
aussi notre BITD et j'ai donc signé un
mandat ce matin au délégué général pour
l'armement pour faire un premier tour de
piste en quelque sorte de nos
industriels pour définir aussi les
stocks les calendriers de livraison
négocier les coûts unitaires évidemment
aussi de nos matériels bateau avion et
ce qui nous permettra aux alentours du
mois de mars avril avec même la première
ministre et l'ensemble du gouvernement
de présenter ses toits programmation
militaire on conseille des ministres et
de venir devant vous l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat à horizon du mois
de mai et du mois de juin prochain mais
j'aurai l'occasion de répondre à vos
questions dans quelques instants en
commission merci Monsieur député merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Karen et Rodie
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
le 8 mars dernier Emmanuel Macron
proclamé sur le mans nous n'avons pas le
droit de régresser sur ce sujet de
l'égalité femme homme hier le ministre
Rister admettait les femmes sont
pénalisées par le report de l'âge légal
moins d'un an c'est par ses propos quel
aveu d'échec et bien pour une fois je
vais donner raison au ministre oui votre
réforme va toucher encore plus durement
les femmes nous les femmes devrons
travailler encore plus longtemps que les
hommes l'étude d'impact de votre funeste
réforme est claire l'âge de départ à la
retraite des femmes nées dans les années
80 par exemple augmentera deux fois plus
que celui des hommes nous les femmes
auront une retraite plus faible alors
que nous pensions sont déjà inférieurs
de 40% celle des hommes selon l'étude
d'impact vos mesurettes pourraient
augmenter les pensions des femmes au max
au grand maximum de 2,2 % soit 28 euros
par mois en moyenne mais reporter de
deux ans l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite revient au thé aux femmes 24
mois de pension soit une perte de 30 000
euros sur la retraite cumulée
j'ai fait le calcul pour compenser cette
perte une femme qui part à 64 ans devait
vivre jusqu'à 153 ans c'est absurde oui
votre réforme est une réforme contre les
femmes madame la Première ministre
vous avez dit le 14 janvier dernier
notre projet porte des progrès
concrets pour les femmes l'âge
d'annulation de la décote et maintenu à
67 ans pour un départ à taux plein mais
encore heureux allez vous pourrir la vie
des aides soignants des anciens de
maternelles des ouvrières des employés
de toutes les femmes de ce pays
mais nous devrions nous mettre à genoux
pour vous remercier de vous permettre
dans votre grande miséricorde de
continuer à travailler jusqu'à 67 ans
pour obtenir le taux plein automatique
comme doivent malheureusement le faire
19% d'entre nous madame la Première
ministre allez vous continuer encore
longtemps vous essuyez les pieds sur
votre grande cause du quinquennat
je vous remercie la parole
est un monsieur Olivier du soft ministre
du Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée vous avez débuté votre question
en disant les femmes vont devoir
travailler plus longtemps que les hommes
c'est une affirmation lapidaire et
mensongère l'âge de départ l'âge de
légal de départ des femmes comme des
hommes est évidemment le même la durée
de cotisations requise telle que votée
en 2013 était évidemment la même ce que
montre l'étude d'impact et ce sur quoi
vous vous plaisez à appuyer c'est que
progressivement l'âge effectif de départ
des femmes va se rapprocher de celui des
hommes mais en 2030 comme après l'âge
effectif de départ des femmes restera
inférieur à l'âge de départ des hommes
il y a certains rapprochements mais ça
reste inférieur et dire comme vous
l'avez fait que nous demandions aux
femmes de travailler plus longtemps et
mensonger il n'a qu'un objectif c'est
d'inquiéter au-delà de ce rappel toutes
les mesures que nous avons prises que la
première ministre a présenté tout à
l'heure vise à mieux protéger les femmes
et notamment les plus fragiles tenir
compte des trimestres cotisés au titre
de l’assurance vieillesse pour les
parents foyers tant pour l'éligibilité
au minimum de pension que l'éligibilité
au départ anticipées dans les carrières
longues c'est une mesure de protection
des femmes la seule mise en oeuvre de la
retraite minimum garantie quand on sait
que 50 % des retraités femmes ont une
retraite inférieure à 1000 euros brutes
c'est une protection qui bénéficie pour
les deux tiers des crédits la mobilise
aux femmes ce projet met des protections
nouvelles pour les femmes et en
particulier pour les femmes qui ont les
carrières les plus hachées les moins
pépiées et donc les retraites les plus
basses vous montez sur un point vous n'y
allez progrès sur le second
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
vous avez une seconde
[Musique]
votre réforme est inhumaine injustifiée
vous le savez écoute une seconde la
parole est à Monsieur Christian Baptiste
pour le groupe socialiste
la présidente mesdames messieurs les
ministres Michel collègues il y a de
cela quelques jours mon cher collègue
m'a été bronzé
à juste titre sur les impacts qu'aurait
la réforme des retraites dans les
territoires dix d'outre-mer pour autant
la question posée revêtait une
importance particulière surtout
lorsqu'on sait que le projet de réforme
des retraites tel que présenté par vos
soins à vocation à s'appliquer non
seulement en France hexagonale mais
aussi sur le territoire dit d'outre-mer
monsieur le ministre comment
comment pensez-vous une réforme des
retraites qui se voudrait universelle
sans pour autant prendre en
considération les spécificités des
territoires ultramarins pour rappel et
ce n'est pas moi qui l'avance mais les
études sérieuses à l'instar des rapports
publiés par l'Insee en juillet 2022 ou
encore les données émanant de la CNAV ou
de la GIC à le chômage systémique et les
spécificités structurelles économiques
de notre territoire expose nos
travailleurs à des carrières hachées
bien souvent sous rémunérés de leur
permettant pas le moment venu de partir
à la retraite avec une pension descente
et complète
9 à 15% des retraités des départements
et régions did outre-mer sont considérés
comme étant en situation de grande
pauvreté contre 1% en moyenne en France
métropole hexagonale
un autre côté qui réside dans les
territoires du commerce en moyenne une
pension inférieure de 10 à 17 % à ce que
perçoit le Seigneur qui vit en France
hexagonale elle est là à la réalité à
l'instar des éléments évoqués ci-dessus
ma question est donc la suivante
pouvez-vous nous garantir que le projet
de réforme des retraites introduit par
vos soins et de nature à garantir une
équitaine de traitement entre les
traités entre le retraité de la France
hexagonale et si et ceux des territoires
dit d'outre-mer dans la positive merci
de nous indiquer précisément les
paramètres portant en considération les
spécifices la parole l'état Monsieur
Olivier du soft ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion merci
monsieur madame la Présidente par des
animaux sur le député Baptiste en
complément la réponse que j'ai apporté à
Monsieur le Député riman je voudrais
simplement vous apporter les précisions
suivantes sur la prise en compte des
spécificités en outre-mer première
spécificité la réforme que nous
présentons avec la première ministre
s'appliquera au département d'outre-mer
les territoires d'outre-mer qui ont
notre statue qui est un statut
départemental ont un système qui
l'aurait particulier ça paraît une
évidence mais les bandes le rappeler
deuxième particularité la situation de
Mayotte à Mayotte le régime obligatoire
de retraite ne date que de 1987 et nous
savons que les retraités actuels en
général une carrière composée
malheureusement seulement de 9 années
cotisées ça se traduit par des retraites
extrêmement basses et ça se traduit par
des modalités de calcul de l'accès au
minimum contributif qui sont
particuliers et adaptés il y a ensuite
un chantier que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure aussi concernant les salariés
agricoles non les territoires de
Guadeloupe et de la Réunion qui
nécessitent que les partenaires sociaux
en charge du régime complémentaire agir
Carco puisse travailler pour étendre la
couverture agir Carco à ces deux
territoires au bénéfice des salariés
agricoles ceux du régime général étant
déjà couvert par ailleurs vous me dites
finalement mais comment est-ce que cette
réforme va s'appliquer territoire
d'outre-mer et quels sont les résultats
ou en tout cas l'impact cela peut avoir
il est double le fait de l'appliquer de
manière similaire
identique à ce qui se passera en France
hexagonale permet d'une part de
prolonger les carrières comme nous
l'avons fait mais dans des territoires
où là effectivement de départ et déjà
supérieur au prochain âge légal
d'ouverture des droits ce qui lui donne
peut-être un caractère moins mordant il
y a une autre caractéristique de la
réforme qui va bénéficier aux assurés
d'outre-mer c'est le fait que nous
réévalions que nous remontions le niveau
de la pension minimale à 85% du SMIC
c'est effectivement conditionné nous
l'avons dit à une carrière complète mais
les trois quarts de l'augmentation
nécessaire pour atteindre cet objectif
sont une augmentation du minimum
contributif majoré qui est accessible
dès qu'un assuré à cotisé à hauteur de
30 années soit 120 trimestres dans sa
carrière beaucoup des assurés actuels et
des retraites actuelles outre-mer pour
ainsi en bénéficier merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Philippe bolo pour le groupe
démocrate merci Madame présidente
monsieur le ministre de la transition
écologique j'associe à ma question mes
collègues des circonscriptions
concernées après les codes du Finistère
en décembre après celle de la Vendée
début janvier c'est désormais les
rivages de la Loire-Atlantique qui sont
souillées par des vagues de billes de
plastique cette pollution est
catastrophique et irréversible par
millions les billes de plastique
envahissent les zones littorales rendant
leur nettoyage tellement fastidieux
qu'il en devient impossible les dégâts
de cette pollution sont considérables
pour la biodiversité marine poisson et
oiseaux ingèrent ces microbilles qui
confondent avec leur nourriture au-delà
de la faune marine la pollution va
impacter le tourisme et l'économie
locale sans parler des impacts encore
méconnus de la présence de ces
microplastiques sur le long terme pour
les milieux et pour la chaîne trophique
marine la situation provoque une émotion
légitime les maires des Sables-d'Olonne
et de Pornic suivi par la présidente de
la région des Pays de la Loire emporté
plainte contre X plusieurs associations
ont également saisi la justice aux côtés
des élus et des associations l'État a
lui-même décidé de porter plainte
monsieur le ministre comment
envisagez-vous de mobiliser vos services
scientifiques et techniques afin de
mener les investigations indispensables
pour identifier la source de la
pollution et ses responsables l'arrivée
des billes de plastique sur nos côtes
démontrent que le programme volontaire
cleanweep porté par l'industrie
plastique pour éviter les pertes de ses
billes dans l'environnement est
insuffisant la législation doit être
renforcée la loi GEC de 2020 impose aux
entreprises les obligations pour éviter
les pertes de billes de plastique dans
l'environnement monsieur le ministre des
moyens de contrôle ont-ils été mis en
place pour s'assurer de l'application de
ce que nous avons voté dans cette
hémicycle la pollution marine par les
billes de plastique est un phénomène
mondial
qui impose une prise de conscience
internationale monsieur le ministre
envisagez-vous de porter la voix de la
France sur ce sujet lors de la deuxième
session des négociations du traité
international sur la pollution plastique
qui serait qui se déroulera à Paris au
printemps 2023
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
bolo
ce que nous vivons est un scandale
absolu une marée blanche qui vous
l'avait dit après la Vendée le Finistère
le Morbihan touche tout particulièrement
la Loire-Atlantique de quoi parlons-nous
de granulés qui font entre 4 et 5 mm de
diamètre extrêmement complexe à ramasser
qui atteignent parfois des
concentrations de 100 à 200 granulés
plastiques industriels par mètre carré
compliqué à ramasser
s'insérant dans les écosystèmes ingérés
par l'ensemble des animaux et laissant
le désarroi des élus des associations
qui pourtant comme ça a été le cas à
Pornic à la fin de la semaine dernière
essaye de se mobiliser le gouvernement
est révolté juin la parole aux actes
nous avons avec Hervé Berville mon
collègue secrétaire d'État à la mer
signé le dépôt de plainte auprès du
Procureur de la République à la minute
où nous nous parlons les experts du
centre de documentation et de recherche
sont sur place à la fois pour regarder
les procédés pour améliorer
l'exfiltration mais surtout pour
déterminer l'origine d'où ça vient vous
l'avez dit la loi AGEC a posé un
principe en 2020 des décrets
d'applications ont été pris depuis le
1er janvier 2022 notre pays est un des
rares à imposé à tous les sites
industriels au port aux plateformes
logistiques des dispositifs de
séparation de filtres qui permettent de
capter ces billes si elle devait
s'échapper et les audits pour la
première année d'analyse sont sur le
point d'être rendu public quel est le
sujet très vraisemblablement celui de
conteneur qui se sont échoués voir d'un
certain armateurs indélicat qui les ont
laissé sans rien dire la recherche des
causes elle est évidente la pour la
suite et les tout autant fin mai à
l'Unesco la France accueillera
effectivement la deuxième session de
négociation pour l'élimination des
traités des produits plastiques dans la
continuité du rapport de l'OPEX par
exemple que vous avez signé et de nos
engagements nous ferons de ce sujet un
des marqueurs clés du combat contre le
plastique je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Christelle PETEX
Levet pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé de la prévention la France connaît
un point de non-retours de notre système
de santé ma question vous paraît
peut-être redondante vue et revue oui
mais malheureusement elle est toujours
au cœur des préoccupations de chaque
citoyen et son importance et capitales
comment ne pas en avoir conscience cela
ne dépasse pas un jour au cours duquel
nous ne sommes pas sollicités à sujet et
que répondre
urgence hôpitaux médecine de ville et de
proximité tous se sont incompris face à
la pénurie de soignants à la saturation
au sein de leur établissement ainsi que
leurs conditions de travail dégradées et
quand il propose des projets visant à
améliorer les systèmes de santé ils ne
sont bien souvent pas soutenus ou
n'entre pas dans les cases des projets
de l'État nous n'en sommes plus aux
réponses mais aux actes un objectif
commun avec des mécanismes adaptés à
chaque territoire dans mon département
nous formons le personnel soignant et
quelques mois plus tard il part
travailler en Suisse voisine des
exemples tels il en existe des dizaines
pour chaque département pour soigner
notre le système de santé plusieurs
leviers ayant du bon sens dès demain
libérons les médecins de consultation
inutiles telles que celles pour
récupérer une ordonnance et respecter le
parcours de soins imposer revenons au
choix de médecin libre redonnons des
conditions de travail digne revalorisons
les salaires et les consultations
réduisons les tâches administratives et
une action qui aurait dû se faire hier
réintégrons les soignants non vaccinés
mais que cherchez-vous les
professionnels de santé ne sont pas
responsables des erreurs de la politique
de santé émoignée par les gouvernements
successifs et qui ont conduit à la crise
actuelle notre pays s'enlise dans des
politiques inefficaces qui ne
parviennent pas à soigner les maux de
notre système de santé il en faut d'ores
et déjà le constat le plan annoncé
récemment ne suffira pas je vous le
demande monsieur le ministre quand
allez-vous réellement engager des
responsabilités des actions efficaces et
durables pour notre santé
je vous remercie ma chère collègue la
parole est à Monsieur François borrone
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
peut être levée je vous remercie de
confirmer que la dégradation du système
ne vient pas de d'aujourd'hui ni de ces
dernières années mais de décennies de
destruction de notre système de santé
alors l'objectif est assez clair pour le
gouvernement prendre soin des Françaises
et des Français mais aussi et surtout
prendre soin de ceux qui les soignent
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été faites
je ne reviens pas sur enfin la
suppression du numerus clausus sur le
Ségur de la santé mais le contexte nous
impose d'aller plus vite et d'aller plus
loin le président de la République a
fixé les rails sur trois principes et
ses principes sont d'ailleurs issus des
sénères de territoire donc bien à
l'échelle des territoires tout d'abord
travailler territoire par territoire
parce que les solutions sont différentes
d'un territoire à l'autre ensuite la
complémentarité entre les acteurs pour
arrêter cette concurrence que ce soit
entre le public et le privé ou que ce
soit entre les c'est un aide et
paramédicaux et puis également
travailler sur des organisations à
l'échelle humaine cette fois-ci revenir
à la notion de service revenir à la
notion de CPTs par chaque territoire à
court terme c'est à dire dans les dans
les six mois qui viennent outre le
continuer l'augmentation des formations
il faut redonner du temps soignant
redonner du temps médical parce que
c'est la solution la plus efficace
aujourd'hui pour cela les médecins les
soignants ne doivent faire que du soin
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'exercice CD par
des assistants médicaux en ville mis en
place dans le quinquennat précédent mais
également avec un exercice aidé à
l'hôpital en remettant des personnels
administratifs auprès des services la
plus-value de chaque professionnel de
santé doit être reconnu dans les
parcours de soins enfin au sein de ces
équipes soignantes autour du médecin
traitant un engagement vis-à-vis des
Français et des Français c'est un
médecin traitant pour tous ceux qui sont
en a aidé aujourd'hui et qui n'en n'ont
pas un médecin traitant leur sera
proposé avant la fin de l'année c'est
également une continuité des soins qui
sera assurée dans chaque territoire
vis-à-vis des professionnels de santé
une reconnaissance de la pénibilité dans
la poursuite de ce que nous avons fait
déjà cet été la qualité de vie au
travail qui va permettre de redonner du
sens et enfin un nouveau pacte sur
l'attractivité à travailler justement
avec les territoires parce que d'être
activité est différente et la fuite des
professionnels est différente de
territoires à territoire je vous
remercie merci
des grands discours c'est bien être
réactif avec des solutions immédiates
c'est encore mieux je vous remercie je
vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Sandra rigole
pour le groupe écologiste
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues cette
question s'adresse à Madame la Ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
vendredi dernier l'élection de notre
collègue karine bencheck a été annulé
dans la 9e circonscription des Français
hors de France c'est pourquoi parce que
vous avez fait une erreur et votre faute
punit les électeurs et les électrices de
cette circonscription les prix ventes de
tout député et les prix donnaient lu
dans le travail et je souhaite le
souligner aujourd'hui au service de la
démocratie et de ses concitoyens nous
manque beaucoup
le Conseil constitutionnel juge et
garant de la sincérité de nos élections
à constater des dysfonctionnements dans
l'envoi de SMS permettant aux électeurs
en Algérie de voter en ligne je le cite
alors même que cette circonstance n'est
imputable ni au candidat élu ni aux
autres candidats il y a lieu d'annuler
les opérations électorales contestées
madame la ministre l'organisation du
vote à l'étranger et votre
responsabilité l'annulation prononcée
par le Conseil constitutionnel et votre
échec pourtant tout au long de l'année
2022 vos services ont cessé d'envoyer à
nos compatriotes des messages faisant
l'éloge de l'organisation de ce vote
électronique comment le rassurer dès
lors
à tous ces électeurs concernés que cette
procédure est et reste fiable que
faites-vous pour garantir le droit de
vote effectif de nos compatriotes
établies au Maghreb et en Afrique de
l'Ouest lors de la prochaine partiel qui
arrive sous peu il reste vous allez me
dire le vote allure mais les bureaux de
vote sont trop peu nombreux trop
éloignés insuffisants alors allez voir
enfin proposer un nombre suffisant
adapté ou au moins maintenir ce qui
avait été ouvert en 2022 je rappelle
comme 2017 le gouvernement avait renoncé
à organiser invoque électronique privant
de nombreux compatriotes de vote trop
éloignés des bureaux les chiffres de la
participation étaient à ce moment-là
tragique madame la ministre à ma
question est simple allez-vous enfin
essayer de donner les moyens de lutter
contre l'abstention des Français
habitants hors de France
la parole est Madame Laurence bonne
secrétaire d'État chargé de l'Europe
madame madame la présidente madame la
députée rigolait effectivement le
Conseil constitutionnel a rendu vendredi
19 janvier 2 décisions par lesquelles il
a décidé l'annulation des opérations
électorales qui se sont déroulées le 14
et 18 juin 2022 dans la deuxième et
neuvième circonscription des Français de
l'étranger les dysfonctionnements que
vous mentionnez qui est qui ont été
relevés par le Conseil constitutionnel
ne porte pas sur la sécurité ni sur
l'intégrité du système de vote
électronique il porte sur des problèmes
de réception par certains électeurs en
Argentine en Algérie de mot de passe et
d'identifiant requis pour voter par
internet les électeurs devaient en
référencer un mot de passe reçu par SMS
et un identifiant reçu par courriel pour
pouvoir voter le recours à deux canaux
distincts répondaient à une exigence
évidente de sécurité
l'opérateur téléphonique retenu pour la
mise en oeuvre du vote électronique
avait tout fait pour remédier aux
dysfonctionnements constaté mais il n'y
ait pas parvenu auprès de tous les
opérateurs téléphoniques à l'étranger
madame la députée le gouvernement est
attaché au progrès qu'a représenté le
vote électronique qui a permis
d'accroître fortement la participation
des Français de l'étranger aux élections
législatives nous tirons pleinement les
enseignements de cette première
utilisation du vote électronique afin
d'allier la plus grande sécurité à notre
souhait d'un accès le plus large au vote
pour nous concitoyens de l'étranger et
maintiendront ces votes électroniques
améliorés merci je vous remercie madame
la ministre la parole est à Madame Agnès
Carrel pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse monsieur le
ministre comme beaucoup de mes collègues
assis sur ses bancs mais aussi comme
beaucoup de Français je suis
particulièrement inquiète du manque
d'enseignants remplaçant dans ma
circonscription j'ai été interpellé par
des directeurs d'école et des
responsables de parents d'élèves qui se
trouvent démunis face à des classes sans
remplaçant dans l'une des écoles nous
sommes
à peu près à 92 jours alors pas à peu
près excusez-moi mais précisément à 92
jours sans école depuis la rentrée pour
synthèse élèves dans une autre école
depuis le 30 novembre des élèves d'une
classe de maternelle se retrouvent sans
enseignante leur enseignante est en
congé pathologique d'ailleurs s'agissant
d'un 80% les élèves conservent des cours
le jeudi mais non pas d'enseignement les
autres jours ils sont repartis répartis
dans les autres classes les autres
enseignants Palli dans l'urgence les
élèves peanassader les enseignants se
retrouvent avec des classes de 27 à 28
élèves plus complexes et difficiles à
gérer en termes de suivi des acquis il y
a même il a même été parfois conseillé
aux parents de garder leurs enfants à la
maison dans une autre classe une
enseignante absente pour raison de santé
et parfois remplacer une heure le matin
mais elle est appelée sur un autre
remplacement dans la journée il doit
laisser les élèves la rétrise avec
laquelle je me suis entretenue Pen a
répondu à toutes les sollicitations
parfois de remplacer en disponible nous
avons que tous les recrutements sont
difficiles et qu'à la rentrée le nombre
d'enseignants étaient insuffisants
monsieur le ministre les heures
d'enseignement perdu pour ses enfants ne
seront jamais remplacés la pétanque est
là mais pas l'enseignant le retard dans
les apprentissages toutes ces bases qui
s'installent dans les petites classes
notamment la construction du langage le
manque d'acquis dans les fondamentaux la
démotivation et même la perte de repère
dans une classe qui n'est pas la leur et
je ne parle pas des sorties scolaires
qui deviennent inexistantes sont des
conséquences non négligées négligeables
pour ces élèves qui nous inquiètent
beaucoup aussi monsieur le ministre pour
assurer les familles pouvez-vous nous
dire quelle mesure pérenne mettez-vous
en place pour que chaque classe de
chaque établissement de France puisse
disposer de remplaçants et de solutions
dans les meilleurs délais pour donner à
chaque parent la visibilité et
l'assurance car complètement arrive dans
les meilleurs délais merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Papa n'diaya et
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députés
Karel la question du remplacement des
enseignants est évidemment une question
essentielle essentielle pour la
continuité pédagogique dans le premier
degré comme vous le savez il existe un
dispositif spécifique c'est celui des
brigades de remplacement qui rassemblent
environ 9% des effectifs de professeurs
des écoles néanmoins comme vous le savez
également le premier degré est touché
par des difficultés de recrutement donc
y compris les brigades de remplacement
et nous devons répondre à cela par trois
voix la première c'est celle de la
revalorisation j'en ai parlé à votre
collègue la seconde pour les territoires
les plus en difficulté c'est
l'organisation de concours exceptionnels
pour titulariser les professeurs
contractuels pour sa première session le
concours est ouvert dans les académies
de Créteil de Versailles et de Guyane
de manière plus structurelle nous devons
réfléchir au recrutement et à la
formation des professeurs des écoles par
exemple par le recrutement et la
formation d'élèves professeurs qui
seraient titularisé au bout de 5 ans et
c'est une hypothèse sur laquelle nous
travaillons actuellement s'agissant du
second degré la question du remplacement
doit également être prise à bras le
corps d'une part par la revalorisation
bien entendu mais aussi par les missions
complémentaires qui font l'objet des
concertations et qui inclut cette
question des remplacements pour les
remplacements de courte durée en effet
ce qui est en jeu aujourd'hui ce sont
les remplacements de courte durée les
remplacements de moins de deux semaines
qui en effet ont des effets parfois
extrêmement dommageables sur la
continuité pédagogique dans un certain
nombre de départements et donc nous nous
attaquons à cette question et vous
verrez la différence
à partir de la rentrée prochaine
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Sébastien de
l'augu pour le groupe la France
insoumise
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre
c'est avec une immense émotion que je
m'adresse à vous accompagné du collectif
des familles de victimes d'assassinats
présentent aujourd'hui
il y a 6 mois j'ai été élu député mais
au quotidien j'ai l'impression de
travailler pour les pompes funèbres
chaque semaine madame la Première
ministre je marche dans le sang je
marche vraiment dans le sang Marseille
c'est 500 homicides depuis Kiji c'est 66
fusillades et 36 meurtres l'année
dernière oui l'année 2022 et l'année la
plus meurtrière la semaine dernière
c'est un père de famille de 46 ans qui
s'est fait tuer d'une balle dans la tête
à consola le quartier de mon enfance et
celui de Monsieur Rome
l'insécurité qui ne cesse de rendre
l'univers de nos quartiers de plus en
plus sinistre et les habitants des
quartiers pauvres de Marseille ont aussi
le droit à une sûreté madame la Première
ministre que je passe t-il
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente
députée monsieur le député comme vous je
veux évidemment m'inquiéter de ce qui se
passe à Marseille depuis de trop longues
années et qui vous le savez monsieur le
député et le fait d'une guerre de gang
d'une guerre de pointe d'île d'une
guerre de la drogue qui a enquisté la
cité marseillaise depuis trop longtemps
et dans l'assassinat qui a eu lieu mais
je laisserai évidemment la police
judiciaire et le procureur de la
République communiqué si la personne
n'était pas connue pour stupéfiant elle
était connue pour les services de police
et vous savez très bien que la situation
que nous trouvons à Marseille
malheureusement c'est une situation de
réglement de compte et malgré les très
nombreux meurtres qui existent à
Marseille 29 en 2022 et ont été évités
par les services de police ce qui me
permet d'ailleurs de souligner monsieur
le député que vous pourriez un peu plus
soutenir les services de police plutôt
que les insulter comme vous avez fait
encore extrêmement récemment
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur delogu
j'étais tellement près que vos éléments
de langage changeront rien il faut
changer votre politique contre la drogue
et le trafic d'armes il faut arrêter
avec votre politique du chiffre cela ne
fonctionne pas je vous demande donc en
tant que député des Bouches-du-Rhône
député de terrain de démanteler la BAC
de mettre des places de police de
proximité qui retissera les liens avec
la population et avec la police
républicaine nous avons besoin d'une
police judiciaire forte
investissez dans les services publics
mais aussi surtout réagissez vite nos
quartiers s'embrassent madame la
Première ministre vous avez pas voulu
nous répondre nous sommes si nous sommes
inutiles des habitants des quartiers
populaires de Marseille de France à part
entière ou des Français entre
entièrement à part excusez-moi c'est mes
16 heures
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
je crois que on ne pourrait mieux
résumer malheureusement notre différence
vous voulez démonter les policiers
là-bas que nous voulons démonter le
trafic de drogue monsieur le député
et vos propos
vos propos
vos propos vos propos vos propos comme
tous ceux comme tous ceux de la France
insoumise sont absolument scandaleux
Monsieur Mélenchon les policiers sont
des barbares soyez prudent car les
vérités
s'il vous plaît sont très bonnes à
écouter de la part de ceux qui n'aiment
pas la police c'est les policiers qui
sont courageux dans les cités de
Marseille ce ne sont pas les voyous et
vous devriez avoir honte de soutenir
ainsi ce qui attaquent les policiers
risquent de leur vie alors vive la
police nationale qui protège les
honnêtes citoyens et dans cette
hémicycle républicain plutôt que de dire
que les policiers sont des barbares
plutôt que démanteler la police
nationale vous devriez protéger la
police plutôt que d'être complice je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Nathalie dans il
y a pas deux interventions il y en a
qu'une Madame Nathalie da Conceiçao
Carvalo pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le garde des sceaux vendredi
dernier le meurtrier de la jeune Axel
Dorier a été condamné à 12 ans de prison
s'il ne nous appartient ni à vous ni à
nous de commenter ce verdict au nom de
la séparation des pouvoirs il n'en reste
pas moins que bon nombre de nos
compatriotes et choqués notamment après
avoir entendu l'avocat du coupable
expliqué qu'il pourra dès l'année
prochaine je cite bénéficier d'un
bracelet probatoire voilà une triste
illustration de votre politique pénale
rappelle à la loi stage de citoyenneté
composition pénale travaux d'intérêt
général effectués ou non peine de prison
avec sursis peine de prison ferme
immédiatement transformé en aménagement
de peine ou jamais mise à exécution
voilà ce que risque ce qui vole raquette
insulte menace agresse blesse trafic et
ce depuis le 1er janvier 2023 tout
condamné à moins de deux ans de
détention sort trois mois avant sa fin
de peine bien sûr il y a des exceptions
à la règle mais vous acceptez de laisser
sortir des coupables de trafic de
stupéfiants de vol de violence avec ou
sans armes si l'actualité politique au
judiciaire n'évoquait pas si
régulièrement des récidivistes on
pourrait se dire que c'est seulement la
notion même de justice qui est mise à
mal mais dans les faits ce sont nos
compatriotes qui font les frais de cette
politique je vous le dis clairement
monsieur le garde des sceaux et je relai
ici les paroles de bon nombre de
magistrats il y aura un jour un raté
depuis des décennies la politique des
peines repose sur un dogme évitez de
sanctionner et lorsque des peines sont
prononcées évitez la prison cette
libération anticipée inquiète à juste
titre les Français monsieur le garde des
sceaux ma question est simple quand
allez-vous changer de politique pénale
qu'en mettez-vous en place une politique
pénale qui protège les Français et leur
rendent enfin confiance dans la justice
je vous remercie la parole est à Éric
Dupond-Moretti ministre de la Justice
garde des sceaux merci madame la
présidente madame la députée d'un
extrême à l'autre toujours les mêmes
vieilles recettes les mêmes casseroles
et les mauvais produits qui donnent
naturellement de mauvais plats alors si
c'est pour changer de politique pénale
pour aller vers la vôtre je vais vous
dire vous commencez vous commencez par
critiquer une décision de justice rendu
très vraisemblablement par la
souveraineté populaire bel hommage que
vous lui rendez je voudrais quand même
vous dire que la Constitution n'est pas
une vétille une anecdote une broutille
un texte superfétatoire mais il consacre
madame la députée la totale indépendance
de la justice dans notre pays et le jour
madame ou comme vous le souhaitez on
touchera à l'indépendance de la justice
alors nous aurons basculer vers le
totalitarisme maintenant
s'agissant des libération
une contrainte vous retenez le mot
libération vous devriez entendre
également contraintes il s'agit
d'interdire des sorties sèches ça
concerne les gens qui ont été condamnés
à qui ils restent moins de 2 ans
d'emprisonnement et les trois derniers
mois effectivement une libération sous
contrainte sous le contrôle d'un juge de
l'ordre judiciaire peut-être envisagé si
il y a un hébergement
s'il vous plaît laissez le garde des
choses il y a un hébergement d'ailleurs
les premiers chiffres que nous avons
c'est que 41% en bénéficié d'une
libération sous contrainte et donc près
de 60% n'ont pas bénéficié de cette
libération vous savez ce que ça consacre
ça éviter les sorties sèches ça consacre
un manque ça consacre la réinsertion et
la lutte contre la récidive vous ne
comprenez rien à la procédure pénale si
ce n'est la trique
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
séance des questions au Gouvernement est
terminée la séance est suspendue